Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss. Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss.
Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss.
An einem Donnerstag, kurz nach 10, es ist wieder mal Kraftwerkzeit. Den Track kennt ihr wahrscheinlich, wenn ihr treue Hörer des Chaos Radio seid. Das geht heute in die 164. Ausgabe und es geht um Schließfragen, also darum, wie Türen zugemacht werden und möglicherweise auch zubleiben. Oder vielleicht auch nicht, wenn man genau weiß, wie man sie wieder aufmacht. Um das zu klären, sind heute zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club Andreas und Henrik. Hallo, guten Abend. Und außerdem noch der Mann vom Fach TM, Simon. Guten Abend. Es geht heute, wie gesagt, um Türen. Als ich erfahren habe, dass ihr was über dieses Thema machen wollt, dachte ich so, ja, da kann ich endlich mal die beiden Geschichten erzählen, die mir dazu passiert sind. Die eine war sonntags umziehen, Wohnungstür fällt, ist Schloss und ist zu. Oh mein Gott. Wie kriegt man die Tür jetzt wieder auf? Man ruft natürlich so ein komischer Schlüsseldienst an und der sagt, ja klar, wir kommen vorbei, kommt dann in drei Stunden vorbei, will dann irgendwie, also ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, ist schon eine Weile her, aber auf jeden Fall über 100 Euro. Und alles was passiert ist, dass der Typ ankommt, eine kleine Plastikkarte aus seiner Tasche zieht, die in die Tür irgendwie reinfrickelt und dann ist die Tür auf nach einer Minute. Und dann denke ich mir, aha, also so eine Art Herrschaftswissen, wenn man das gewusst hätte, hätte man das auch selber machen können. In der Tat, ich hab mich geguckt, es gibt sechs von diesen Karten für 15 Euro, irgendwie im Netz zu klicken, kann man also in der Tat selber machen. Das ist meine eine Begegnung mit sicheren Türen oder beziehungsweise wie man Türen aufmacht, die eigentlich zu sehen sollten. Die andere ist, ich habe mich neulich mal umgetan nach so einem In-the-Cloud-Service, da geht es um Adressverwaltung und bin dann bei einem Dienstleiter, der meinte so, ja, wir verwalten ihre Adressen, das wird alles bei uns auf den Server abgeschmackt, das ist aber ganz sicher, weil unsere Serverräume, die sind mit Biometrie-Schlössern versehen, jawohl. Genau und ich dachte, das ist doch eigentlich mal, das sind so zwei schöne, extreme, bald zu Türen und vielleicht könnten wir heute beide mal klären. Also die eine Frage, die ich an euch habe, ist quasi, wie kriege ich meine Tür auf, wenn sie zu ist, aber ich sie aufhalten will. Die andere Frage ist, sagt mal, mein Server hinter den Biometrie-Schlössern, wie sich erst der denn eigentlich? Wo fangen wir denn an?
Wir fangen mal damit an, dass 15 Euro natürlich 15 Euro zu viel sind. Also man hat ja manchmal das Problem, man steht draußen und man hat auch gar keine 15 Euro mehr, sich um seine Karte zu kaufen. Außerdem gibt es die am Sonntag nicht im Supermarkt, weil erstens der Supermarkt nicht offen hat und zweitens die Karten nicht da sind. Der beliebte Trick ist, sich dann ein Draht zu besorgen. Da muss man irgendwie mal so ein bisschen rumlaufen, läuft in den nächsten Baumarkt, da gibt es dann Draht und dann gibt es dann auch die passenden Zangen. Da macht man sich so ein Stückchen Draht ab. Und ja, das reicht dann im Prinzip schon Knick links, Knick rechts, damit man in die Ecke kommt und ein geübter Handgriff, zack und die Tür ist offen.
Ein geübter Handgriff. Ich glaube, da kommen wir zum entscheidenden Punkt. Was heißt ein geübter Handgriff? Was macht man denn da?
Also wenn man sich so eine Tür anguckt, also wir gehen mal davon aus, die ist nicht abgeschlossen, sondern die ist nur zugeschnappt. Also der Schnapper, wenn man sich den anguckt, der wird ja reingeschoben. Also wenn die Tür von der einen Seite drückt, wird er reingeschoben. Irgendwann rastet er ein in dem Loch, das da in der Tür ist. Und an der anderen Seite hat er halt keine Schräge, sondern eine Gerade und deswegen kommt er nicht wieder raus. Und was man jetzt tut, sowohl mit diesen Karten, als auch mit dem entsprechend gebogenen Draht, ist, dass man hinter diese Falle, heißt es glaube ich in der Fachsprache, oder? Dass man hinter die Falle geht und gegen diese schräge Fläche drückt und dann so ein bisschen rüttelt und dann bewegt sich diese Falle wieder rein und dann ist die Tür offen.
So einfach kann sein, wenn man es kann. Hast du das mal geübt? Kannst du das selber?
Ich hab mal ein bisschen geübt. Ich bin nicht besonders gut dabei. Also es gibt...
Wie viele Türen hast du dabei kaputt gemacht?
Bei solchen Öffnungen habe ich keine Türen kaputt gemacht. Ich habe auch tatsächlich einmal, als es mir wirklich auch passiert ist, dass die Tür zugefallen ist, die Tür mit der Methode wieder aufgekriegt. Das war ein bisschen eine trickige Geschichte. Da hätte der Draht aus dem Supermarkt nicht funktioniert, weil es eine gute Tür war, mit wenig Platz. Aber mit einer Teflon beschichteten Plastikarte habe ich es dann hingekriegt.
Die Teflon-Karten sind toll. Ich hatte genau das gleiche Problem. Tür zugefallen, man kennt ja die Tricks, die man im Fernsehen so sieht, so Kreditkarte nehmen oder Personalausweise oder so. Das funktioniert tatsächlich in der Wirklichkeit nicht so richtig toll. Aber die Teflon-Karten, die sind groß genug und da funktioniert das dann auch.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich mal eine Tür mit einem Perso aufgekriegt, das ist richtig doll dringend, weil ich brauchte einen neuen Perso.
Genau, meiner hatte auch.
Geht das denn eigentlich mit dem neuen Perso? Nein, geil, anderes Thema.
Nein, geht nicht.
Die andere Frage, die man sich jetzt vielleicht noch mal kurz stellen muss, wenn man einen Schritt zurückgeht, ist, ist Hacker eigentlich eher Computer? Warum Schlösser? Was hat das miteinander zu tun?
Es ist so ein bisschen derselbe Sport, nur anders. Also erstmal natürlich, man ist neugierig, was wohl ein Orten ist, wo man nicht hin darf. Das kennt bestimmt jeder noch aus seiner Kindheit. Und Hacker nehmen das ja so ein bisschen in ihrem wachsenden Leben mit, irgendwie mal herauszufinden, herauszufinden, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält und was ist eigentlich hinter dieser Tür, wo drauf steht, dass man sie immer geschlossen halten soll. Daher kommt das glaube ich so ein bisschen. Auch die Faszination mit Technologie und dem Know-how und so weiter und so fort.
Eine Art verwandter Sport also.
Ja, ich habe auch tatsächlich, also der Begriff des Hackers kommt ja vom MIT. Damals in den 50ern noch der Modelleisenbahn Club, wo also irgendwie die damaligen Nerds unter riesigen Modelleisenbahntischen lagen und dann mit Relaissteuerungen gebaut haben. Später kam dann Computer dazu. Und ich habe tatsächlich das mit dem Schloss öffnen gelernt. Es ist auch schon wieder 22 Jahre her, dass ich diesen Download gemacht habe. Es gab das MIT Lockpicking Guide, das einem erklärt hat, wie Schlösser funktionieren, wie das mit dem Öffnen der Schlösser funktioniert. Also der Zusammenhang scheint auch schon länger da zu sein.
Ich möchte euch an dieser Stelle aufrufen, wenn ihr jetzt gerade von den neuartigen Rundfunkumfangsgeräten sitzt und auch eine Geschichte zu Schlössern habt. Also entweder zugefallen nicht aufgekriegt oder wie ihr selber euch beigebracht habt, wie das geht, dann könnt ihr heute gerne Folgendes tun. Und Andreas und Henrik vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier sind. Ich weiß, wenn ich euch beiden die Frage stellen würde, wäre die Antwort ganz klar und deutlich nein. Simon, deswegen an dich die Frage. Vielleicht gibt es eine andere als der Mann vom Fach quasi. Gibt es ein sicheres Schloss?
Nein. Es gibt Schlösser, die sind sicherer als andere. Und man muss immer abwägen, wie sicher braucht man es selber für entweder sein persönliches Gefühl oder die Werte, die man absichern will. Und muss dann entweder verschiedene Schließtechniken kombinieren und oder sich da jemand hinsetzen, der aufpasst.
So, so, jemand hinsetzen, der aufpasst. Aber die meisten, die vom Rad sitzen, haben ja eine einfache Wohnungstür. Was ist denn sozusagen, wenn dich jemand fragt, ich möchte, dass meine Wohnung standardmäßig sicher ist, ich bin jetzt nicht, also es ist nicht so, dass ich glaube, dass irgendwie die Geheimnisse hinter mir her sind, sondern ich möchte einfach eine sichere Tür haben, die davor schützt, dass Leute einfach so in meine Wohnung reinkommen.
Ja, da gibt es auch sehr große Unterschiede. Es gibt einfache Zylinder, die man vor, nämlich im Baumarkt zum Beispiel bekommen kann, aus dem Preissegment unter 10 Euro. Da sind meistens wenige Stifte drin, also wenige Teile, die die Schließabfrage ausmachen. Und die haben dann außerdem noch große Toleranzen und wenig Abstufungen. Und dadurch wenig mögliche Schließverscheinigkeiten.
Ok, jetzt haben wir schon mal Stifte, Abstufungen, Schließverscheinigkeiten.
Toleranzen, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Was hat sie mit den Stiften auf sich?
Also so einen ganz klassischen Flachschlüssel. Da sind ja meistens unten Zacken drin.
Also der Bart quasi.
Der Bart ja. Obwohl der Schließbart ja noch von den ganz alten Bartschnitzeln kommt. Das sind ja in den meisten heutzutage verwendeten Zylindern sind ja diese Flachschlüssel, wo diese Zacken drin sind. Und unter jedem Zacken ist ein Stift. Und der bewegt sich oder bewegt sich nicht.
Also das heißt, wenn ich den Schlüssel in das Schloss reinschiebe, sozusagen macht der Zacke oder die Spitze oder die Eintiefung in dem Schlüssel, verschiebt einen Stift in dem Schloss. Und weil das alles stimmt, geht das Schloss auf.
Ja, weil da ist ja so ein runder Kern, der sich dreht. Und da drin sind immer zwei Stifte. Einer ist im Kern und einer ist im Gehäuse. Und wenn die Zacken richtig lang sind, dann ist der Übergang zwischen beiden Stiften genau da, wo sich der Kern dreht. Und dann kann man schließen.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig fortzusetzen. Ich krieg's gerade so hin. Das kann man bestimmt auch irgendwo online nachschlagen. Habt ihr mal schnell einen Link, wo man da vielleicht das als Bild angucken kann?
Das ist doch bestimmt bei Wikipedia unter Schließzylindern.
Genau, das könnt ihr mal rausfinden. Ihr könnt auch gerne hier anrufen und sagen, wenn ihr was gefunden habt. So, jetzt hat man also diese Spitzen und diese Stifte. Und was hat das mit der Toleranz auf sich? Heißt das dann, der Abstand zwischen den beiden Stiften kann ja nicht wirklich groß sein? Die müssen ja aufeinander liegen.
Ich glaube, das mit der Toleranz ist dann meine Abteilung, weil ihr macht irgendwie die sicheren Schlösser und ich mache sie wieder auf. Die sicheren nicht, aber da kommt nämlich das Lockpicking ins Spiel. Also wir haben, ich muss mal gleich mal gucken, ob es bei Wikipedia Schließzylinder ein schönes Bild gibt.
Vier schöne Bilder.
Gibt es, da gibt es so ein schönes Bild. Also Wikipedia klicken, wenn ihr euch das nicht vorstellen könnt. Man steckt da also diesen Schlüssel rein. Dann gibt es irgendwie im Normalfall, beim normalen Schloss fünf Stifte verschiedener Länge und die Längen entsprechen der Tiefe der Zacken und dann werden die hochgeschoben. Und wenn die alle sozusagen gleichzeitig auf der richtigen Höhe sind, kann man den Schlüssel rumdrehen. Was macht man jetzt, wenn man nicht den richtigen Schlüssel hat? Dann müsste man ja theoretisch mit einem Werkzeug rein und alle diese fünf Stifte gleichzeitig auf die richtige Höhe heben und dann kann man schließen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Jetzt ist es aber so, wenn man, gibt es einen deutschen Begriff für, im Englischen heißt es Tension Wrench, wenn man irgendwie einen, sagen wir mal Schraubenzieher für den Anfang, wenn man so einen Schraubenzieher in den Schloss rinsteckt und ein bisschen zur Seite dreht, also es ist so verkantet, dann passiert Folgendes. Dann durch die Toleranzen, also irgendwie mechanische Fertigung ist nicht alles absolut gleich, gibt es einen von diesen fünf Stiften, der als erstes auf das Gehäuse trifft, der sozusagen das Schloss am Weiterdrehen hindert. Und die anderen sind zwar auch noch nicht richtig drin, aber die sind noch nicht dran, weil die liegen ein bisschen weiter hinten wegen der Toleranz. Wenn man jetzt, also okay, man hat in der einen Hand den Schraubenzieher dreht, jetzt nimmt man mit der anderen Hand eine Büroklammer, schiebt die rein und fängt jetzt an an diesen Stiften so ein bisschen rumzutasten. Da wird man den finden, der gerade klemmt. Und wenn man den dann langsam hochschiebt, dann macht das irgendwann einen Klick. Das Schloss dreht sich ein klein bisschen weiter, nämlich genau um die Menge, wie dieses Loch sich durch die Toleranz nach links oder rechts verschoben hat. Und dann hängt das am zweiten Stift. Und der erste, der ist jetzt quasi auf. Also da ist die richtige Stelle da. Und dadurch, dass es sich schon weiter gedreht hat, kann der auch nicht zurückfallen. Und dann hat man den ersten Pin. Und dann geht man mit der Büroklammer weiter. Dann findet man irgendwann den zweiten, an dem es gerade hängt, schiebt den hoch, macht das wieder Klick. Dann findet man den dritten und so weiter und so fort, bis das Schloss auf ist. Das ist so Lockpicking für Anfänger erklärt.
Und das heißt, die Toleranz gibt dann an, wie groß diese Abstände zwischen den verschiedenen Stiften oder Pins, wie du sie gerade genannt hast, sind. Und ich vermute dann mal, da sind wir wieder beim Baumarktschloss. Je billiger das Schloss, desto größer die Toleranz, desto einfacher das Klaken.
Ich finde es nicht verstanden.
Ah, ja. Gut, jetzt hast du gesagt, dass sozusagen da fangen die Schlösser an. Also für unteren Zehner im Baumarkt mit großen Toleranzen. Also für so jemand wie Andreas dann irgendwie leicht aufzumachen. Dann geht es wahrscheinlich unendlich nach oben. Aber wo kommt denn dann die Spanne, wo man sagt, das ist sicher?
Also es geht ja auch um die Menge der Stifte, die da drin sind. Und einfache Zylinder haben vier oder fünf solcher Stifte. Und bei etwas besseren Zylinder geht es hoch bis sechs, sieben oder wenn zwei Stifte rein sind, bis hin zu zehn Stiften im Zylinder.
Okay. Und das ist dann in welcher Preisspanne?
Ja, zwischen 40 und 70 Euro.
Also ist das noch bezahlbar? Oder reden wir dann schon von einem kleinen Wagen, den man in eine Schließanlage investiert?
Das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Streitthema im alltäglichen Leben, weil die Menschen stellen sich ein Fernseher für 2000 Euro hin und eine Hi-Fi-Anlage und haben dann 10 Euro Zylinder in der Tür, mit dem sie das letztendlich in gewisser Weise absichern.
Jetzt haben wir ja aber dieses Schloss, das ist aber nur ein Teil von der Tür, auch ein relativ kleiner. Was ist denn eigentlich mit dem Rest von der Tür? Wie sieht eine sichere Tür eigentlich aus? Also ich hab mal eben zum Beispiel gehört, dass in den Altbauwohnungen haben die Wohnungstüren ja immer diese viereckigen Verzierungen quasi drin, die nennt man glaube ich Kassetten, und ich hab mal jemand mir gesagt, das wäre eine total beliebte Einbruchsmethode, die einfach einzutreten.
Richtig.
Ah ja.
Und dahingehend hilft bei Altbautüren, indem man innen etwas aufsetzt, z.B. ein Blech oder eine Holzplatte. Das ist letztendlich dann Geschmackssache. Also ich favorisiere selber das Holz, weil es zusätzlich noch Wärmbedingungen und Scheisschritte bringt.
Also da geht es nur darum, irgendwie eine stabile Sache hinterzubauen, aber es muss jetzt aber nicht was Tolles sein quasi.
Nein, es sollte natürlich dann entweder ein Blech oder ein Holz sein, was durchtrittfest ist.
Also keine Sparnplatte?
Sondern zum Beispiel eine Multiplexplatte.
Okay. Und dann ist die Frage, ein Schloss oder mehrere? Also oder andersrum, könnte man vielleicht fragen, ein gutes Schloss oder lieber drei billige?
Ich würde sagen eher zwei Schlösser, also mehr als eins, weil das sieht so aus, man hat auf jeden Fall erst mal ein zusätzliches Schloss an der Tür. Weil es gibt ja immer zwei Arten von Einbrechern. Der Einbrecher, der von Tür zu Tür geht und der Einbrecher, der zu dir möchte. Also der zweite ist schon sehr schwierig. Der, der von Tür zu Tür geht, nimmt sich natürlich eine Tür, die nur ein einfaches Hauptschloss hat und nicht ein oder zwei Zusatzschlösser. Weil das ist ja schon von vornherein viel schwieriger für ihn. Denn was hinter der Tür ist, wenn man von Tür zu Tür geht, weiß man ja nicht.
Was ist erstmal nicht okay? Und wenn der dann wirklich zu mir will?
Dann musst du mit dir ins Reine kommen, warum der zu dir will und wie wichtig ihm das ist.
Ich hab mich über Britney Spears lustig gemacht. Oh mein Gott. Dann ist man schon quasi im Bereich der Spekulation. Also dann hängst du davon ab, wie viel der rein investiert, reinzukommen.
Richtig, das ist ja immer eine Frage des Aufwands oder der Interesse. Denn es ist einfach wie mit vielen Sachen im Leben, Dinge, die wir schaffen, können wir auch wieder kaputt machen.
Wo wir jetzt gerade über Geld und Kleinwagenpreise sprechen, kommen wir gleich nochmal zu dem Türöffnungsgeschäft. Es gibt ja nur viele Leute, denen das irgendwie passiert ist. Und man hört ja Horrorstories. Also ich selber hab gesagt, am Sonntag über 100 Euro. Und dann gibt es Leute, die erzählen von mehreren 100 Euro. Gibt es irgendwie so eine artrielle Preise oder macht da wirklich einfach jeder, was er will?
Es gibt viele Leute, die da machen, was sie wollen. Es gibt seriöse Fachhändler, die ein Geschäft haben, lange an einer Adresse sind und halt immer wieder mit Kunden in Kontakt kommen. Und es gibt Firmen, weswegen halt die Branche auch sehr in Verrufenheit geraten ist, die halt dieses, sag ich jetzt mal einfach, ganz banal Abzockgeschäft machen. Also die AAA XY heißen, im Telefonbuch als erstes kommen, sind meistens Callcenter, die dahinter sitzen, die bundesweit ihre Telefonnummern streuen und es dann an Sub-Sub-Sub-Unternehmer geben, die dann ihre eigenen Preise machen. Also wenn einem das passiert, kann ich nur empfehlen, sich im Branchebuch jemanden aus der Nähe zu suchen, an dessen Geschäft man vielleicht schon mal vorbeigelaufen ist. Und zu hoffen, dass dieser einen Notdienst hat.
Und wie ist das so generell? Ich meine natürlich ist es dann teurer, irgendwie nachts oder an einem Wochenende würdest du dann sagen, wenn es geht, dann vielleicht lieber verzichten und zu normalen Geschäftszeiten das machen?
Ja, das kommt dann auf die Situation, ob man wirklich in die Wohnung muss. Selbstverständlich ist eine außergewöhnliche Zeit, eine außergewöhnliche Situation rechtfertigt in meinen Augen in gewisser Weise auch ein Mehrpreis. Der kann meinetwegen auch bis zu dem Doppelten vom Tage sein.
Was ist ein normaler Preis? Also nochmal so über den Daumen gepeilt.
In Berlin, ein normaler Preis. Man muss erst mal gucken, ist die Tür zugefallen?
Okay, also ganz klassische Situation. Ich würde sagen, ich gehe aus der Tür raus, schlage die Tür zu und denke so, ah scheiße, Schlüssel vergessen. So, dann ruf ich Schlüsseldienst an. Was nimmt der dann? Es ist Dienstag 15 Uhr in Berlin Mitte.
Ich würde sagen, irgendwas zwischen 40 und 80 Euro.
Okay, und dann sagst du sozusagen, Wochenende, Nachts, möglicherweise...
Zwischen 100 und 200 Euro ist noch vertretbar.
Okay, so viel also zu den Leuten, die unsere Türen professionell wieder aufmachen. Wir beschäftigen uns jetzt weiter mit der Technik, um die es ja heute eigentlich gehen soll im Chaosradio, wo ihr auch gerne anrufen könnt, unter 0331 70 97 110, falls ihr eine Schlüsselschließ-
oder Türzu-
oder Türaufgeschichte habt. Wir haben jetzt Christoph am Telefon, den nehmen wir vielleicht erst noch dran. Der hat mal was erlebt mit Schlössern. Hallo Christoph. Oh, München, herzlich willkommen. Bis heute der Anrufer, der am weitesten weg ist.
Ja, ich komme eigentlich aus Köln, das wäre noch weiter, aber bin ja eine Diaspora in München.
Du Armer.
Und freue mich auch, hier gibt es einen CCC in Lokalen, aber das Radio ist natürlich trotzdem. Also meine Geschichte ist ein bisschen her. Das war, ich war 17, ich bin jetzt 44, also ein paar Jahre ist das her. Und leider passiert mir das immer noch, dass ich ab und zu einen Schlüssel verliere. Und damals habe ich in so einem zweistöckigen oder dreistöckigen Haus gewohnt, wo so gegenüber, man kannte alle. Und gegenüber hatten die meinen Schlüssel bei sich drin. Und wir haben probiert bei mir die Tür aufzumachen, also bei meinen Eltern, bei denen ich damals gewohnt habe. Weil ich wusste, dass die hatten vorne noch, das ist vielleicht auch ganz interessant zu der Technik, früher waren oftmals Türblätter so von vorne verschraubt. Und dann konnte man den Griff abmachen. Und dahinter war so eine Art Vierkant, mit dem man im Prinzip die Klinke runterdrücken konnte. Also vorne halt ein Griff. Und dahinter auf der anderen Seite die Türklinke. Wenn man vorne das Blatt aufgemacht hat, ist heute halt von der Versicherung her auch nicht erlaubt, dass vorne noch Schrauben dran sind. Aber früher war das häufig so. Und dann konnte man halt mit einer dicken Zange einfach die Klinke drehen sozusagen. Und bei uns war aber diese Klinke so stark abgefeilt, oder dieser Vierkant so stark abgefeilt, dass die Zange einfach nicht gegriffen hat. Und das passierte relativ häufig. Und nachdem man jedes Mal wieder ein bisschen rumgekratzt hat, klappte das überhaupt nicht mehr mit der Zange. Und daraufhin kam ich dann irgendwann auf die Idee nach einer halben Stunde, komm wir machen das bei meinen Nachbarn gegenüber jetzt und holen meinen Schlüssel, um bei mir die Tür aufzumachen. Und wie der Zufall es so wollte, wir hatten halt bei mir die Tür, den Griff schon auf dem Boden liegen und auf der anderen Seite schön abgeschraubt ordentlich, Schrauben auf den Boden gelegt, Zange in die Hand und ich hör unten wie die Tür aufgeht, dem ersten im Erdgeschoss. Und ich seh die Nachbarn kommen und ich denk so, Scheiß was machen wir hier, Tür schnell wieder dran, sodass die Schrauben schnell, also den Griff wieder dran, Schrauben dran gesteckt, so einigermaßen und auf der anderen Seite versucht die Tür aufzumachen. Und so blöd es klingt, aber in dem Moment hat das geklappt, auf der anderen Seite, dass die Tür aufging. Also bei uns war die Tür auf, auf der anderen Seite kamen die und nahmen den Griff in die Hand und hatten den Griff in der Hand. Das ist so nach und zu so, wie erklär ich das jetzt? Und ich so, ja, ja, Christoph, erzähl nichts, mach den Griff wieder dran.
Wir haben es also nicht übel genommen?
Nee, also ich weiß nicht genau, was sie sich gedacht haben, aber ich glaub, jede Erklärung hätte unglaubwürdig geklungen.
Es gibt so Situationen, wo man einfach gar nichts sagt.
Ja, das war dann glaube ich auch so. Also ich hab das Ding wieder dran geschraubt. Aber das ist halt auch prinzipiell heutzutage öfters auch noch eine Möglichkeit. Rein theoretisch, wenn man vorne den Griff abnehmen kann, dass dahinter irgendwo der Rest sozusagen von der anderen Seite von der Türklinke noch ist. Also rein theoretisch möglich.
Und wenn man sich mit der Zange nicht gegriffen kriegt, dann kann man sich auch ein Schraubenzieher nehmen und einen Hammer und mal kurz bonk machen, dann fällt die Klinke auf der anderen Seite raus und man hat ein Vierkantloch.
Ja, genau, das wäre sehr...
zum Beispiel...
Und ansonsten, ich fand den alten Personalausweis super. Das war übrigens ein Türöffner. Also deswegen bin ich auch gegen den neuen Personalausweis.
Dafür gibt es ja verschiedene Gründe. Jetzt wissen wir also, dass man auch nicht mal sozusagen am Schloss rumvermarkten muss, sondern auch einfach an der Türklinke manchmal rumpumeln kann. Christoph, vielen Dank, haben wir wieder was gelernt. Im Zweifelsfall immer ein Bestellungsgeschenk dabei haben, wenn man fremde Türen aufmacht. So, wenn ihr eine ähnliche Geschichte erlebt habt, mit eurer Tür oder vielleicht auch mit der Tür eines anderen.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Das sind jetzt die alten Türen, das geht heutzutage nicht mehr. Oder mit dem Abschrauben?
Naja, es gibt Leute, die benutzen heute immer noch die alten Beschläge. Also ich hab erst vor zwei Wochen das letzte Mal genauso bei einer Kundin den Beschlag abgeschraubt, mit der Zange die Tür aufgemacht, und die sah sehr erstaunt aus.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, wie der Gesichtsausdruck von Leuten, bei denen die Tür aufmacht, ist dann häufig so, hä? Oder wie die dann erschreckt?
Es gibt Türen, die, auch wenn sie nur in Anführungsstrichen zugezogen sind, man da schon so eine dreiviertel Stunde dran rum vorstellt. Wenn man den Anspruch hat, es unbeschädigt zu öffnen, da gibt es auch andere Meinungen. Aber das ist halt die hohe Prämisse, eine Tür möglichst unbeschadet oder mit dem geringstmöglichen Schaden zu öffnen. Diese Sache mit dem Vierkant funktioniert witzigerweise auch bei aktuellen Beschlägen. Wenn sie nicht richtig festgeschraubt sind, kommt man nämlich zwischen den Beschlägen und die Tür. Und da gibt es Werkzeuge für, die dann dazwischen parken und dann den Vierkant wie eine Klinke bedienen.
Also es gibt extra Werkzeuge, die dafür gemacht sind?
Ja, die man aber auch selber machen könnte.
Es gibt immer irgendwann eine Technik dafür. Kommen wir noch mal zu dem ganz anderen Extrem. Das ist ja alles noch sehr mechanisch. Mit den Schlössern, was wir jetzt geredet haben. Wie sieht das eigentlich mit der Elektronik aus? Kommt da irgendwas? Oder ist das so ähnlich wie bei den Wahlen, wo wir sagen, na gut, das hätten wir doch lieber ganz analog auch weiterhin. Auch wenn sich das aufmachen lässt. Mit vertretbarem Aufwand kann man vertretbar Leute abschrecken. Wie sieht das aus?
Also es gibt da viele verschiedene Sachen. Aber wir leben in einem extrem konservativen Land, gerade was die Sicherheitstechnik angeht. Es gibt andere Länder, wo über die Hälfte der Haustüren voll elektronisch verschlossen werden. Und bei uns ist das noch sehr unüblich und findet man Wändern eher in Firmen.
Was sind denn da diese Systeme, mit denen man so Türen elektronisch verschließt?
Na ja, da gibt es ja die verschiedensten. Also von den ganz einfachen, wo man einfach bloß den Schließzylinder ersetzt durch irgendwas, was Elektronik betrieben ist, was man dann wahrscheinlich eher im Privatumfeld einsetzen würde, bis hin zu solchen, wo kaum noch was von einem herkömmlichen Schloss dran ist, wo dann einfach bloß irgendwie ein Lesegerät ist, was irgendwie ein Rechtjungsmedium einliest und dann irgendwie irgendwas Elektrisches in Gang setzt. Also vom einfachen Schnapper, der ja dann auch wieder nur so sicher ist, wie das mit dem Kreditkarten aufmachen, bis hin zu richtig Motorschlössern, bis richtig irgendwie motorisierten Türen oder sowas.
Was sind also motorisierte Türen? Okay, da geht die Tür auf, in dem ein Motor angeworfen wird und der hält die Tür zu, wenn man das nicht mehr hat. Aber was sind denn Motor-Schlösser?
Wo man oder Simon sollte das am besten mal erklären, der...
Ja, es gibt Schlösser, die haben in dem... Also man muss ja erstmal anders sagen. Es gibt ja einen Zylinder, das ist das, wo man die Schlüssel reinsteckt. In der Tür oder in dem Türblatt steckt dann das Schloss und außen dran hat man den Beschlag. So es gibt Schlösser, die einen Motor innen drin haben und wo man ein Draht anschließen kann, wo man dann ein Signal gibt und wo der Riegel und auch die Falle dann motorisiert rein und rausfahren können. Das hat den Vorteil, dass wenn man so eine Lösung mit einem Kartenlesegerät oder einer anderen Authentifizierung haben oder einen Förderer, der einen Knopf drückt, dass dann der Riegel elektronisch reinfährt, die Falle elektronisch reinfährt und dann ein Türantrieb die Tür wie von Geisterhand öffnet.
Und wenn ich einen Schlüssel habe, also geht das dann noch mit einem richtigen Schlüssel oder geht das dann nur über, keine Ahnung, Tastatur, Lese, Medium, was auch immer?
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten. Also es gibt Motorschlösser, wo man eine Lochung für einen Zylinder drin hat, wo man mit einem Schlüssel aufschließen kann und die Tür dann von Hand aufdrücken kann. Oder man kann anstelle des Kartenlesegeräts neben der Tür auch ein Schlüsseltaster haben, also eine Einheit, wo ein Halbzylinder drin steckt, wo man auch schließen kann.
Halbzylinder heißt sozusagen, da kann man nur von einer Seite Schlüssel reinstecken?
Richtig, weil auf der anderen Seite ist ja der Wand- oder Gehäusekasten.
Und wenn man schließt, legt man quasi einen Schalter um?
Richtig, wie so ein Taster, der dann an dieser Schließnase vom Zylinder sitzt.
Haben denn diese Systeme dann irgendwie neue Angriffspunkte?
Ja natürlich, wenn ich mir einen Hammer nehme und eine Kiste von der Wand hole, sind da zwei Drähte und wenn ich miteinander verbinde, ist die Tür auf......unter Umständen, ja.
Das ist wirklich so einfach.
Wenn es falsch gebaut ist, ja.
Wenn es falsch gebaut ist. Es gibt da die blödesten Bugs, die da passieren können. Also ein System, das habe ich mal gesehen, ist auch ein elektronisches, wo man quasi den Zylinder ersetzt. Und draußen dran ist ein Griff, an dem man drehen kann. Und der sich aber erstmal frei dreht. Und wenn man das richtige elektronische Schloss, also die richtige Karte davor hält, dann zieht ein Elektromagnet an. Und dann wird der Griff, den man draußen hat, verbunden mit dem Teil hinten dran, den man drehen kann. Dann schließt man ganz normal das Schloss auf. Kann man hacken, indem man einen starken, ringförmigen Magneten nimmt. Indem man einfach da drüben liegt und macht das Klack. Und dann plötzlich kann man dran schrauben, ohne sich auch nur ein bisschen mit der Elektronik beschäftigt zu haben.
Ist das bei einer großen Firma verwendet worden? Oder wo hast du das gesehen?
Der deprimierende Weise wurde das mal auf einer großen Technikmesse vollfüllt.
Das sind dann halt auch die Einzelsysteme, die kleinen Systeme, die dann tatsächlich mehr so für den Privatgebrauch oder kleine Firmen gedacht sind. Wo man dann wirklich bloß einen Schließzylinder mit ersetzen würde.
Hat der Verkäufer sich ja vorher anders argumentiert.
Es ist natürlich klar, wenn man nur den Schließzylinder gegen sowas austauscht, hat man nicht so viel Aufwand, kostet nicht so viel, man muss nicht eine Tür rumbohren. Während wenn man einen Motorschloss in den ganzen Kram einbaut, dann muss man fast die halbe Tür ersetzen. Das ist dann natürlich ein anderer Aufwand. Das macht man nur, wenn man das Gebäude gerade neu baut zum Beispiel.
Apropos Tür ersetzen, nämlich auch eine lustige Geschichte. Schaffen die noch für die Nachrichten? Schaffen wir noch? Habe ich auch in Hellersdorf gewohnt, mal vor einem Jahr, das ist auch schon wieder 15 Jahre her.
Gott seid ihr alle alt.
Ja, ich bin nicht, ich find's furchtbar. Und eines Morgens hörte ich eine Stimme rufen, als ich noch total übermüdet im Bett lag, weil ich natürlich die ganze Nacht gehackt hatte, komme ich raus, ist meine Tür offen, steht jemand, meint irgendwie, warum ist denn hier die Tür offen? Guck ich mir das näher an, da hat es tatsächlich durch den Luftdruck irgendwie die Tür aufgedrückt und das Schloss rausgerissen. War ein Sturm draußen, ne? Dachte ich mir, das geht nicht. Hab irgendwie bei der Hausverwaltung angerufen, die meinten ja, kein Problem, wir haben hier Sicherheitstüren. Sind sie also gekommen, haben die komplette Tür ausgetauscht. Also einen Stahlrahmen irgendwie mit einer soliden Stahltür, mit irgendwie Schließungen in drei Richtungen und einem ordentlichen Schloss. Halbe Jahr später, selbe Situation, ganze Nacht gehackt, geschlafen und ich denke irgendwie, oh, was ist das denn für ein Krach? Ich kam morgens nach Hause, genau, ich kam morgens nach Hause und es war schon so ein bisschen warm und feucht im Hausflur. Ich leg mich hin. Ziemlich später geht ein tierischer Krach los, denke ich, das sind die Bauarbeiter, die fixen das Wasserrohr. Krach, es macht Krach, es macht Krach. 20 Minuten macht es Krach. Irgendwann denke ich mir, das ist aber ganz schön laut, ich geh mal gucken, komme also zu meiner Tür, mach die Tür auf, steht der Typ vom Schlüsseldienst da und wie mit einer Bohrmaschine, der die letzten 20 Minuten an meinem Schloss rumgebohrt hatte, ganz enttäuscht meinte, jetzt hatte ich sie fast offen. War ein Rohr geplatzt irgendwie und sie hatten geklingelt bei mir, ich war nicht da, bin offensichtlich in der Zeit gekommen, als sie gerade den Schlüsseldienst geholt hatten. Großartig. Seitdem weiß ich mit der richtigen Tür, hat man eine halbe Stunde Zeit, wenn jemand rein will.
Alles klar, zumindest wenn er keine Panzer bringt. Sehr schön. Wir klären das dann gleich noch weiter. Unter anderem würde mich da noch mal interessieren, im Film sieht man immer diese Talenschlösser, diese Tastenkombination, die dann ganz einfach kackt, wenn jemand seinen Kaugummiautomaten ranhält oder so. Wie gesagt, darüber sprechen wir gleich. Wir machen jetzt erst mal das Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und dann geht's hier weiter im Chaosradio.
Zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio ist heute das 164. wie jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Und auch Henrik wird sein Mikro anbekommen. Ganz ungeduldig hier schon. Es sind nämlich drei Leute heute zu Gast. Henrik und Simon. Und es geht heute um, wie heißt es? Schlüsselfragen. Fließfragen. Wie war das Stichwort?
Unauthorized access.
Unauthorized access. Also um Türen geht's quasi, könnte man sagen, und wie man sie aufmacht. Ihr seid heute auch gefragt, wie gesagt. Ich glaube, es gibt da draußen noch ein paar mehr Leute, die schon mal versucht haben, eine Tür aufzumachen. Und das ohne den passenden Schlüssel dabei zu haben. Und die bitte ich folgendes zu tun. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Wobei natürlich so ein paar Horrorgeschichten über Türen, die dann plötzlich doch raufgehen, auch ganz nett werden. Wir waren stehen geblieben bei einer wirklich sicheren Tür, hat man eine halbe Stunde Zeit, zumindest wenn der Typ nur eine Bohrmaschine braucht.
Ja, wenn es ein bisschen schneller gehen muss, gibt es da so Wasserstrahlkanonen. Also die SEKs verwenden sowas, wenn sie vermuten, dass hinter der Tür ein böser Terrorist setzt, der eine Sprengfalle gebaut hat. Handelt es sich dabei um einen echt massiven Stahlzylinder mit einem wirklich kleinen Loch vorne drin, der voller Wasser ist und am Ende ist Sprengstoff. Und dann zündet man den Sprengstoff und dann hat man vorne so einen Wasserstrahl von ungefähr 600 Bar. Und damit kann man also auch in etwas dickere Türen so feinsäuberlich einmal im Schloss herum ein Loch schneiden und dann ist die Tür auf relativ schnell.
Mit Wasser?
Mit Wasser.
Das ist ja großartig. Wie teuer ist sowas?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie dir sowas überhaupt verkaufen würden.
Hört sich aber sehr interessant an. Ich hab mal auch eine Geschichte gehört von Einbrüche in einem Wohnhaus, wo es darum geht, dass sich Leute einen Autoheber, einen Wagenheber genommen haben, einen relativ großen, und haben dann irgendwie noch ein paar, ich weiß gar nicht, Paletten oder Betonblöcke mitgebracht, um an der Gegenwand den abzustürzen, und dann mittels des Autohebers die Tür aufzudrücken.
Einfachen Balken.
Einfachen Balken und einen hydraulischen Wagenheber.
Weil der hat so viel Kraft, dass er sozusagen, dass es dann einfach die Tür wegdrückt.
Und dann die großen Himmel und LKWs hoch.
Stimmt. So gesehen. Ist das eigentlich auch ein plausibles Vorgehen? Oder wie angreifbar ist denn eigentlich dieser Punkt Tür in der Wand? Also das ist ja quasi, wenn die Tür wirklich dicht ist, hilft sie ja trotzdem nichts, wenn ich das ganze Ding einfach rausdrücken kann. Ist das sehr einfach eigentlich? Also ich würde sagen, wenn man nur den Wagenheber den richtigen dabei hat.
In der Regel nicht. Also eine ordentlich gebaute Tür, da ist ja der Rahmen außen so, dass er innen und außen die Wand umschließt. Also das ist bei sehr alten Türen manchmal so, dass es nicht so gut hält. Aber prinzipiell ist es eher eine Schwachstelle, die weiter hinten kommt.
Okay, also das müsste man schon sagen, durchs Mauerwerk dann durch. Alles klar, was ist denn die seltsamste Türöffnungsmethode, von der ihr jemals gehört habt? Also die absurdeste. Ich finde der Wagenheber ist schon relativ weit vorne. Geht es noch besser? Ein Wagenheber, Wasserstrahl.
Also damals beim Abi-Streich haben wir die Scharniere abgeschraubt, die nämlich an der Tür außen lagen. Und dann einfach die ganze Tür rausgenommen.
Auch sehr einfach. Klassiker. Sie haben auch schon kurz gesprochen über elektronische Schlösser, also sagen die, die irgendwie einen Motorschloss gibt, wo der Schließmechanismus quasi mit einem Motor funktioniert, wo die ganze Tür irgendwie per Motor aufgemacht wird. Jetzt ist es ja besonders beliebt in den Actionfilmen, aus denen ja viele Leute ihr gefährliches Halbwissen beziehen, das Türschloss mit einem Nummern-Pad. Also im Supermarkt kann man dann häufig sehen, dass die 1234 irgendwie die Zahl ist, die alle Leute eingeben, weil die total abgenudelt sind. Also wenn die da irgendwie so eine, keine Ahnung, Tür zum Flaschenpfandraum haben oder sowas. Wie sicher sind diese Schlösser? Also diese, nicht die Schlösser, das ist genau die spannende Frage nämlich. Wie sicher ist nämlich das Nummern-Pad?
Das hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, es gibt da zwei Varianten. Das eine ist irgendwie das, was du beschrieben hast, wo man irgendwie schon daran sieht, wo es abgegrabbelt ist, welche Tasten in Frage kommen. Und wenn man dann weiß, es sind vier Ziffern und es gibt vier abgegrabbelte Tasten, na gut, da gibt es nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, nach 24 hat man sie alle durch. Ist also nicht besonders toll und das kann auch immer jemand zugucken. Was tatsächlich ein sehr, sehr sicheres Verfahren ist, also deutlich sicherer als zum Beispiel so was wie Fingerabdrücke oder ähnlicher Kram, sind Nummern-Pads, bei denen sich die Belegung jedes Mal ändert. Das sind also so lange Plexiglasröhren als Tasten, wo man nur, wenn man auch direkt von oben rauf guckt, also man kann dann auch nicht von der Seite gucken, da sieht man nichts, nur wenn man direkt davor steht, von oben rauf guckt, welche Zahl das ist, wo die Belegung jedes Mal wechselt. Und das sind, also wenn natürlich alles andere in Ordnung ist und sie nicht irgendwie mal den Magneten an die richtige Stelle halten kann und die Tür eintreten, muss man ja immer dazu sagen. Also zumindest der Aspekt ist relativ sicher. Also ist eins der besseren Zugangssysteme, das ich kenne.
Was natürlich aber als von der Benutzerakzeptanz vollkommen durchfällt, weil man sich nicht mehr einfach die Reihenfolge merken kann, sondern jedes Mal aktiv hingucken muss, sich den Code merken muss. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn man sich mal seine eigenen Eltern vorstellt.
Ja, das fällt fast wieder unter das Thema Toleranzen. Es gibt ja sehr viele verschiedene Techniken. Auch ein Fingerabdruck kann besser und schlechter eingescannt werden. Also es gibt bei allen Sachen große Toleranzen und auch eine Qualität. Und es gibt auch, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel Fingerabdruck.
Warte mal, ich würde zum Fingerabdrucken ganz später gerne nochmal kommen, weil da gibt es ja auch vom Club sozusagen die Anleitung, wie man sich selber fingerabdruckt. Ich würde gerne erst nochmal bei diesen Keypads bleiben. Habt ihr also gesagt, wenn die Zahlen sich auf den Tasten austauschen, also quasi eine Art Bildschirm sind und man das nicht einsehen kann, dann ist das Keypad erstmal gut. Jetzt habt ihr vorhin bei dem Schloss gesagt, was ein elektronisches Ding hat. Man nimmt das einfach raus, macht zwei Drähte und dann geht das Schloss auch auf. Geht das mit diesen Keypads auch? Oder wird dann irgendeine Art von verschlüsseltem Signal gesendet?
Kommt drauf an, TM.
Okay, wie macht man es richtig?
Also wir haben schon solche Schlösser gesehen, da ist dann tatsächlich das Keypad, ist dann zwar schon mit Drähten, mit dem Schloss verbunden, muss ja irgendwie das übermitteln, aber sendet dann halt nicht einfach nur das so ist jetzt richtig, mach mal auf, das wäre die falsche Art, sondern sendet dann einfach bloß die Zahlenkombination, die man eingegeben hat. Und dann ist die gesamte Elektronik irgendwo anders, vorzugsweise auf der Seite, wo man eigentlich rein will. Also wenn man elektronische Schlösser richtig einbaut, baut man natürlich die Elektronik dorthin in den gesicherten Bereich und nicht außen.
Da hab ich aber auch noch eine gute Geschichte dazu. Es ist irgendwie ein verwandtes Thema, weil irgendwie handelt es sich um einen Tresur und zwar den Tresur eines Geldautomaten. Gelegentlich tauchen ja auf Ebay mal so Komponenten von alten Geldautomaten auf, man kann die sich so ein bisschen angucken. Da gab es tatsächlich eine Generation Geldautomat. Da konnte man außen zwei Schrauben lösen und dann den Deckel aufmachen. Da stand da ein Rechner und der Rechner hatte eine tolle, ich glaube irgendwie IEEE 485, also nicht erst 232, sondern 485 mit einem anderen...
Entschuldigung, eine was?
Eine Schnittstelle. Serielle Schnittstelle. Und zwar acht davon auf einer so langen, irgendwie damals noch ISA-Karte und der PC war da direkt zugänglich, die Kabel, die aus dem PC kamen auch und eine dieser acht Seriellen Schnittstellen war der Geldauswurf am Tresor. Da musste man also nur sagen, ich will Geld haben und dann ist es rausgekommen.
Hat man einfach einen Strom eingelegt oder muss man schon noch irgendein Signal?
Man muss schon noch irgendwie die richtigen 8-Bit-Muster da rein schicken. Ganz einfach war es nicht, aber ja.
Und genauso würde man dann auch solche Schlösser übermitteln, selbst in dem Fall, dass sie den eingegebenen Code an das Schloss übermitteln. Würde man, wenn man das angreifen will, sich einfach irgendwie versuchen, da ein kleines Gerät zu bauen, was man mal unauffällig an einer lauen Sommernacht dort ablegt, wartet, bis der Besitzer den echten Code eingegeben hat, wird von dem Gerät aufgezeichnet, kann man dann später wieder abholen und wieder reingeben.
Das ist natürlich schon wieder, da will jemand wirklich rein und macht sich noch vorbeigehen. Da aber noch die spannende Frage, die, also du sagst ein Gerät und das macht man da ran, da denkt man ja eigentlich so, man muss das an diese Kabel anschließen. Jetzt gab es in letzter Zeit auch so Abstrahlungsdinge. Sind das Ströme dann, wo man auch einfach irgendwo hin in die nächste Nähe ein kleines Plastikkästchen pappt oder?
Oh ja, auch das geht. Also auch das wurde schon gemacht mit Geldautomaten.
Okay, die Frage, wie komme ich sicher zu meinem Geld, ohne einen Geldautomaten zu benutzen, erklären wir dann anders mal?
Ja, das machen wir ein andermal. Über Geld können wir mal eine Sendung machen, erinnere mich dran. Aber wir waren bei Geldautomaten und wir waren bei Pinpads von Geldautomaten und elektronischer Abstrahlung. Wer sich an seinen Physikunterricht dunkel erinnert, in dem Moment, wo sich Elektronen durch einen Leiter bewegen, entstehen magnetische Felder. Und wenn Sie das mal tun, mal nicht tun, entstehen magnetische Wechselfelder. Und da werden dann ganz schnell elektromagnetische Wellen draus. Sprich alles, wo Strom durchfließt. Und wenn man so eine Taste drückt, dann wird ja ein Kontakt geschlossen. Dann fließt der Strom durch die Taste durch. Da entstehen elektromagnetische Wellen. Und das ist das Prinzip der elektromagnetischen Abstrahlung. Und wenn man genau genug hinguckt, kann man tatsächlich an so einem Tastenfeld unterscheiden, welche Taste das war. Weil die Leitungen nicht alle gleich lang sind. Weil eine Taste ist weiter links, eine ist weiter rechts. Damit ist die Frequenz eine andere von der Strahlung, die rauskommt. Also jetzt ganz grob gesprochen, ist natürlich in Wirklichkeit alles komplizierter. Aber auch das hat es schon gegeben, dass man einfach in ein paar Metern Abstand mit dem Befangsgerät stand und das aufgezeichnet hat.
Aber das würde dir wiederum nicht helfen, bei dem Zahlenschloss, das wir gerade besprochen haben, wo sich die Belehrung ständig ändert.
Nee, es sei denn, man hat ein Design, wo die eingegebene Zahl dann wiederum unverschlüsselt auf eine Leitung übertragen wird und die strahlt ab.
Zumal ja die Anzeige, die Zahlen anzeigt, auch selbst wieder strahlt. Also man könnte das eventuell alles gegensechnen.
Oh, also es geht da was, sag mal. Okay, bevor wir jetzt über die Fingerabdrücke sprechen, würden wir kurz mit dem Alex reden. Der meint nämlich, mit fünf Minuten kommt man durch jede Tür. Oder wie meinst du das?
Ja, so ungefähr. Also die elektronischen Schließsysteme sind ja ganz nett. Aber solange du da einen normalen Schließzylinder vorne dran hast, der das Ding zuhält, da brauchst du eigentlich nur eine stabile Schraube reinschrauben und kräftig dran ziehen und dann bricht der Schließzylinder ab. Und innen drin ist dann noch so die Nase, die das Schloss betätigt, den Schlosskasten. Den kannst du dann rumdrehen.
Ja, das klappt oft, aber nicht immer.
Ja, das klappt aber bei, ich würde mal sagen, 90 Prozent Schlösser, weil die allerwenigsten Leute außen so einen mechanischen Schutz haben, dass du die nicht ziehen kannst. Und wenn du ins Baumarkt gehst und kaufst dir einen guten Bohrer, also einen guten Bohrer, richtig gehärtetest Material, dann bohrst du die vorne an und dann brauchst du noch eine gute Schraube. Auch aus gehärtetem Material, dann schraubst du die rein. Das langt so eine halbe bis eine Umdrehung und dann machst du oben noch einen Bahnstahl dran, wo du die durchsteckst und an beide Enden von dem Bahnstahl schraubst du ein Gewinde rein und schraubst ganz normale metrische Schrauben durch. Und dann setzt du die Schraube ins Schloss an und die beiden anderen Schrauben an der Brücke. Mit denen übst du dann Druck auf die Tür aus und dann ziehst du langsam den Zylinder. Irgendwann macht das Knack und lässt der der Mitte auseinander. Dann ziehst du das äußere Teil raus, das Innere kannst du innen rausdrücken und dann hast du nur noch diese Nase, die das ganze Ding betätigt. Und die kannst du dann draußen mit dem kleinen Draht oder so, ungebogenen Nagel oder so, kannst du den betätigen. Nein, aber mein Bruder hat Schlosser gelernt. Er hat mir das im Detail erklärt.
Das gibt es tatsächlich auch als professionelles Öffnungswerkzeug.
Hab ich auch.
Das wird aber viel zu teuer verkauft. Wenn du Zugang zu einer besseren Hobbywerkstatt hast oder vielleicht sogar zu einer Schlosserei, dann baust du dir das Werkzeug dafür in ein paar Minuten selber.
Das kann man sich aber auch in etwas andere Konstruktionen. Du hast vorne auch die Schraube, die du reinschraubst. Dann ist aber hinten eine Gewindestange dran. Und an der Gewindestange am Ende hast du zwei verkonterte Muttern. Und dann hast du da drauf ein Gewicht, was du verschieben kannst auf der Gewindestange.
Ah, ja, dann gibst du den Impuls drauf.
Genau, dann reißt du einmal dran, dann schlägt das Ding hinten an, dann macht es zack und es fliegt durch die Gegend.
Okay, wie lang ist das Ding? Geht das in die Hosentasche?
Na, es geht nicht in die Hosentasche.
Okay, weil die Konstruktion, die ich erklärt hab, die geht in jede Hosentasche. Wenn du dir eine Bundeswehrhose kaufst, in die Hosentasche draus, ein Schlüssel dazu, da schneigt das Ding keine Sau. Da kannst du durch die Gegend laufen damit, da schneigt kein Schwanz.
Da ist man aber definitiv wieder bei guter Zylinder, schlechter Zylinder. Ja, klar. Weil es gibt zum Beispiel auch die Schwachstelle. In dem Fall beim Zylinder ist ja unten das Mittelteil, wo auch die Halteschraube durchgeht. Da ist der Zylinder extrem dünn. Und es gibt aber Produkte, wo die Zylinderkerne in der Schließnase miteinander verbunden sind.
Richtig.
Und dann bricht es unten durch und oben hängen die Kerne zusammen. Und dann hast du echt ein hässliches Problem.
Und weißt du, was du da machen kannst? Wenn die Tür jetzt nicht über extra Zuhaltungen verfügt, weil es gibt ja Türen, die mehrere Zuhaltungen haben. Da kommt es darauf an, wie viele Zuhaltungen die hat. Aber die meisten haben halt eine, vielleicht zwei, wenn es hoch kommt vier. Da gibt es auch so schlaue Leute, die bauen sich in der Tür so im oberen Drittel noch so ein zusätzliches Schloss hinein. Das sieht aus wie so ein zu groß geratenes Auge. Oberes Drittel ist scheiße. Die müssen es eigentlich in unsere Drittel bauen. Wenn du nämlich eine Kante hast, wo du ansetzen kannst, die kannst du mit einem Brett schaffen. Du brauchst ein Brett, das du unten hinlegst. Und dann brauchst du ein sogenanntes Hubmännchen.
Aber alle anderen kennen es nicht.
Du hast das Hubmännchen, eine schreckige Tür, das weiter hinten zu behalten, oder hier ist der Adama.
Okay.
Was ist ein Hubmännchen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Alex, du musst uns mal kurz zuhören. Alex, du musst uns kurz zuhören, wenn wir eine Frage stellen. Was ist dein Hubmännchen?
Ja, so was wie ein Wagenheber. Aber nicht so ein Scherenwagenheber, wie der typischer weiß im Auto dabei ist. Sondern das ist eigentlich ein Hydraulikzylinder. So ein schlankes Teil. Und oben fährt der Zylinder aus und hat einen kleinen gerüffelten Kopf oben dran. Sieht eben aus wie ein kleines Männchen.
Und damit kann man die Tür dann halt aufdrücken.
Genau, an der Seite ist so eine Öse dran gebracht, die die Pumpe betätigt. Und dann kannst du einen Hebel reinstecken zum Pumpen.
Alles klar. Alex, da haben wir noch zwei Möglichkeiten gelernt, wie man eine Tür aufmachen kann. Dafür vielen Dank. Hast du auch ein Hubmännchen in deinem Kofferchen dabei? Aber damit machen die Türen auch kaputt, oder?
Ja, definitiv. Und das ist ja genau die Kunst, möglichst wenig kaputt zu machen. Also wenn die Tür zugeschlossen ist, dann bleibt einem halt selten was anderes übrig. Und dann ist halt die Kunst, möglichst nur den Zylinder zu beschädigen. Und gerade so bei den Rausreißgeschichten, also so Schraube reindrehen in den Kern, ist das durchaus eine gängige Möglichkeit. Es besteht immer das Risiko, dass sich durch die großen Kräfte, die entstehen, und in das Schloss so verformt, dass das Schloss kaputt geht. Und im schlimmsten Fall geht es so kaputt, dass du danach den Riegel nicht mehr rauskriegst und dann hast du ein echtes Problem.
Aber der wirkliche Sport ist ja, es gibt ja Leute, die sich mit dem Öffnen von Schlössern, also dem kunstvollen, mechanischen Öffnen von Schlössern, etwas intensiver beschäftigen. Und der Sport für die wirklich Fortgeschrittenen ist also nicht nur die Tür zerstörungsfrei zu öffnen, sondern sie ohne forensische Spuren zu öffnen. Das heißt, ich hatte ja vorhin erklärt, man irgendwie mit der Büroklampe und dem Schraubenzieher im Schloss kann man also die Pins einzeln runterdrücken bzw. etwas ausgefallteres Werkzeug dafür. Das hinterlässt aber Kratzer auf den Pins. Und wenn man hinterher irgendwie vermutet, da war einer bei mir in der Wohnung, kann man das Schloss ausbauen, kann die unter das Mikroskop liegen und sieht dann die Kratzer. Und die wirklich, wirklich guten Leute hinterlassen dann nicht mehr mehr Kratzer.
Weil sie sozusagen so taktil feinfühlig geworden sind oder weil sie anderes Werkzeug benutzen?
Beides. Beides, sowohl als auch.
Was heißt dann anderes Werkzeug?
Ja zum Beispiel mit Teflon-Beschichtung und natürlich dann jedes mal frisches, damit die Teflon-Beschichtung auch noch heile ist.
Oder aus Hartplastik.
Was ich jetzt übrigens gerne nochmal machen möchte, ist, weil wir die ganze Zeit darüber reden, wie man Türen aufmacht, die eigentlich zu sind. Es gibt ja diese irgendwie Verein der Freunde, der Sperr schließt, irgendwas. Keine Ahnung, es gibt auf jeden Fall so eine Art Codex, welche Türen man dann aufmacht und welche nicht und so vielleicht.
Na, grundsätzlich nur die, wo der Eigentümer des Schlosses die Zustimmung dazu gegeben hat. Also die eigene, oder wenn der Kumpel sagt, ey, ich hab mich ausgeschlossen, lass mich mal rein. Aber wenn der Kumpel sagt, ey, kannst du mir mal die Tür von meiner Nachbarin aufmachen, die hat immer so schicke Unterwäsche, das macht man dann nicht.
Das ist eigentlich gesunder Menschenverstand, aber mit dem gesunden Menschenverstand ist es ja auch so eine Sache, da fällt auch noch eine Tür ins Schloss, deswegen finde ich das keine schlechte Idee, wenn wir das zwischendurch mal sagen. Man weiß ja nie so genau, wo jetzt gerade die ganze Zeit über Schlösser, wir kommen auch noch zu den Fingerabdrücken, das ist mir noch ganz wichtig, aber jetzt nochmal, wo wir gerade noch bei den Schlössern sind, vor zwei oder drei Jahren gab es auf dem Kongress was das hieß, Bumping. Könnt ihr das nochmal erklären?
Willst du, soll ich?
Ja, also Bumping ist eine andere Art, da hat man einen Schlüssel, der gleich tiefe Zacken hat und den steckt man so ein kleines Stück rein und schlägt dann von hinten gegen den Schlüssel. Und dann wieder durch die Toleranzen bleiben die dann, beim Runterspringen, die Stifte an der Stelle hängen, wo der Übergang zwischen Kern und Gehäuse ist. Und dann kann man...
Das ist ein bisschen Impulserhaltung. Wieder mal der ein oder andere, erinnert sich düster an seinen Physikunterricht. Da gibt es dieses tolle Experiment, wo diese 5 Bälle hängen und dann lässt man den Linken von der Seite gegenschlagen und dann springt der Rechte weg. Und wenn man 2 Bälle links dagegen schlagen lässt, dann springen 2 Bälle rechts weg. Das hast du bestimmt auch schon mal gemacht. Und so funktioniert das bei so einem Bumping Key auch. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man mit dem Bumping Key gegen den einen Stift dagegen schlägt, schlägt er den anderen Stift weiter, aber der in der Mitte bleibt stehen. Also man hat ja immer diese 2 Teile des Stiftes. Der eine der außen im Gehäuse steckt, der andere der innen im Zylinder steckt. Mit dem Bumping Key schlägt man von unten gegen die Kombination aus beiden. Das wird aber der Impuls in den oberen übertragen. Das heißt, nur der obere springt weg und der untere bleibt liegen. Das entsteht kurzzeitig eine Lücke zwischen den beiden. Und dann kann man den Schloss öffnen. Das ist Bumping.
Damals hat der Vortragende irgendwas gemacht. Der hat so ein Schloss dabei gehabt, das ist eines der sichersten. Ich versuch das jetzt, vielleicht klappt es vielleicht nicht. Ich gebe mir eine Minute Zeit, nach 30 Sekunden war das Ding offen. Das hörte sich damals an, wie damit kann man wirklich alles aufmachen. Ist das immer noch so? Gibt es da irgendwas dagegen? Hat sich da was geändert? War das vielleicht eine Behauptung, die gar nicht so stimmt?
Also es gibt da viele Sachen, die da erfunden wurden oder ausgedacht wurden, die dagegen wirken sollen. Manche funktionieren besser, manche schlechter. Es ist nach wie vor ein Problem, was oft greift.
Kannst du das in Prozentzahlen aufdrücken? Also wie viel Prozentzahlen?
Schwierig.
Kann man nicht sagen, die handelt es üblichen Schlössern, wie weit die da anfertig sind oder nicht?
Ich glaube mal, alles, was man so im bis 50 Euro Bereich kaufen kann, ist nicht bumpingsicher. Und die Schlösser, die damals aufgemacht wurden, das waren auch schon die 100 Euro Schlösser.
Okay, das ist quasi eine unfehlbare Sache.
Die ist, naja, unfehlbar ist sie, zumindest für das normale Segment. Also wenn man seinen Schließzylinder 15er am Baumarkt gekauft hat, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Das ist auch, das erfordert nicht so viel Übung. Also diese Geschichte mit dem Lockpicking, wenn man wirklich da mit so Stiften reingeht und rumfummelt und so, das erfordert viel Übung. Das ist wie jeder andere Sport, da muss man sich eine Stunde am Tag hinsetzen, damit man das irgendwie ordentlich kann. Und so viel Zeit hat der Einbrecher aber natürlich gar nicht. Und mit so einem Bumpkey, ein Schloss aufzumachen, da muss man mal so 10 Minuten üben, bis man den Dreh raus hat. Dann ist gut.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, brauche ich dafür zumindest einen Schlüsselrohling, der in das Schloss reinpasst?
Das brauchst du, ja. Und es gibt viele bessere Schlösser, wo man dann sein eigenes Schlüsselprofil kriegt, was auch kein anderer nachkaufen kann, beziehungsweise wo man zumindest keine Schlüsselrohlinge kaufen kann, ohne dass sich jemand wundert. Ja, aber auch da gibt es dann Mittel und Wege drumrum.
Irgendwie fern?
Zum Beispiel kann man, wenn man sich von außen das anguckt, sich das selber fertigen, man kann es gießen. Ist natürlich alles wesentlich komplizierter als...
Es geht aber schon wieder in die Richtung großer Aufwand. Genau. Die Frage, die ich mir zur ganzen Zeit schon gestellt habe, ist auch, es geht so zwischen Lockpicking und professionell Türen aufmachen, im Sinne von mit viel Werkzeug. Richtig ausgebildet, auf jeder, auf seinem Gebiet sehr gut.
Wer kriegt schneller die Tür auf?
Das hängt von der Tars-Laune der Tür ab. Nee, es ist auch ein Spaß. Es gibt manchmal Türen, die sind zugezogen, die sind in unter zehn Sekunden offen, beim Lockpicker und beim professionellen Notöffnungsdienst. Und es gibt Türen, wo beide eine Stunde dranhängen, auch wenn sie nur zugezogen sind, wo man die Tür zerstörungsbedingt schnell offen hat, aber wenn man die halt unbeschädigt oder nahezu unbeschädigt öffnen will, doch sehr lange dran braucht. Weil die Tür klemmt oder es reicht ja schon, wenn irgendwie, ja, wenn die Tür in einer Zarge klemmt und man das richtig aufgepickt hat und dann abrutscht, weil es klemmt und dann ist wieder zu und man fängt von vorne an.
Also, ich muss sagen, es gibt ja nicht, dass man sagt, naja, da und da haben die vielleicht einen Vorteil oder so.
Na, die Sport-Lockpicker, die konzentrieren sich ja auch auf das Schloss. Das heißt, wenn die Tür irgendeine andere Schwachstelle hat, interessiert die gar nicht. Sondern da geht es darum, das Schloss aufzumachen. Und irgendwie jemand, der tagtäglich mit Türen zu tun hat, der guckt sich die Tür an, weiß irgendwie, da ist eine Schwachstelle, dort ist eine Schwachstelle, muss mich gar nicht mit dem Schloss beschäftigen. Die Tür geht auch so auf.
Also ich möchte natürlich sagen, eine provozierende Antwort. Man kann also sagen, wenn wir an eine Tür mit einem Schloss kommen, wo der Lockpicker das Schlosstyp sehr lieb hat und sehr trainiert drauf ist, dann ist er da möglicherweise schneller.
Das kann durchaus fix gehen. Wobei da habe ich auch Sachen erlebt, es gibt ja diese Wettbewerbe im Schloss öffnen, wo die Leute irgendwie auch die Schlösser innerhalb von 10 Sekunden öffnen. Und die nehmen dazu aber den ausgebauten Zylinder in die Hand. Das heißt, die stehen nicht vor einer Tür, sondern die haben den Zylinder in der Hand. Und dann kann das derselbe Zylinder sein, den sie also irgendwie unter Wettbewerbsbedingungen, die deutsche Meisterschaft, stehen sie da und machen das Schloss in 5 Sekunden auf. Und dann ist das in der Tür aufgebaut und sie kriegen es nach einer Stunde nicht auf.
Also so ein Zylinder in der Tür, gerade bei einer tiefen Laibung, wo man direkt daneben so eine Kante hat und wenig Platz, kann echt unangenehm zum Arbeiten sein. Gerade beim Picken, wo man ja sehr viel Feingefühl braucht.
Wie ist es eigentlich, der Trick ganz vor Anfang der Sendung, wo man so sagen einfach eine Karte oder irgendwas anderes, flexibles, aber stabiles in die Tür reinschiebt und den Schnapper aufmacht, der kann ja irgendwie verhindert werden, dadurch, dass die Tür sozusagen mehr als eine Ecke hat.
Ja, richtig. Es gibt Türen, die sind mehrfach gefälzt, sagt man dazu. Das macht es in der Tat sehr viel schwieriger. Gerade da ist wichtig, wie so die Toleranzen zwischen Tür und Rahmen sind. Also wenn da sehr viel Luft ist, also wenn man an die Tür anfasst und es schon so richtig ruckelt, dann hat man natürlich sehr viel Platz und kommt mit auch sehr groben Werkzeugen da durch. Und dann geht das natürlich viel einfacher, als wenn die Tür richtig stramm drinnen sitzt und man sie manchmal schon ranziehen muss, um sie überhaupt aufschließen zu können. Und noch mal zu den Sachen, da gibt es auch... Im Film ist es ja immer nur die Kreditkarte, in der der Eimer reingeht und sofort offen ist. In der Praxis ist es dann so, wenn man so engagierte Leute hat, dann kommt man manchmal an Türen, wo dann so zwei abgebrochene Payback-Karten drinstecken. Und ich hab auch schon eine Bankkarte gesehen. Das tut einem schon weh. Weil die Karten sind halt relativ unflexibel und brechen dann irgendwann durch. Die Karten, die man dafür verwendet, sind von einer Art her schon dem alten Personausweis ähnlich, aber noch ein bisschen starrer. Und damit geht das schon besser.
Und jetzt haben wir hier jemanden am Telefon, den wir gleich herannehmen, weil vorher muss ich noch etwas Wichtiges erledigen. Mit Markus Richter heute das Chaos Radio und das heißt natürlich vor allem auch mit dem Chaos Computer Club heutigen Gestalt hier von Henrik und Andreas. Außerdem ist noch Simon dabei, der Mann vom Fach. Und vom Fach heißt heute, es geht um Schlösser öffnen. Wir haben schon über Türen und die verschiedensten Art und Weise, sie zu verschließen und dann auch wieder aufzumachen. Möglicherweise so, dass derjenige auch gar nicht mitkriegt, wie das Ganze aufgemacht wurde, gesprochen. Das könnt ihr euch alles anhören im Podcast nach der Sendung auch. Das können wir jetzt nicht alles nochmal wiederholen, weil dann wird die Sendung um. Chaosradio ist die Internetadresse dazu. Und am Telefon ist jetzt Andi und der ist bei diesem Verein, von dem wir gerade gesprochen haben, der nämlich auf Zeitschlösser öffnet. Hallo Andi.
Ja hallo, ich bin bei dem Verein nicht direkt, aber ich kenne den Verein, die Internetseite. Und da kriegt man sehr viel Info. Also man kann da auch so ein kleines Handbuch runterladen. Und vor allem die Sportgeräte kann man sich da alle angucken.
Und du hast es selber auch schon ausprobiert?
Ich habe Schlösser gelernt. Also ich habe als Berufsschlösser mal gelernt direkt. Und da hat man sowas automatisch so ein bisschen drinne. Also das ist jetzt eine Weile schon her, aber...
Ja leider nur so ein bisschen.
Also mit der heutigen Technik ist das... Das kommt eigentlich schon fast überall rein. Das einzige sind eben diese speziellen Schlösser mit Magneten und das ist nicht für alle Tiere, wo die aus dem Schlüssel direkt Magnete aufgesetzt sind, die man nur mit Keycard kriegt und so was.
Was ist deine liebste Methode, eine verschossene Tür aufzumachen?
Ja, wenn sie nur zugefallen sind, sind die Karten das Beste. Ansonsten, ja.
Flüssiger Stickstoff. Da hat sich jemand ausführlich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Wie viele Schlösser hast du an deiner Tür?
Normale Standard, normale Schubschloss und ein Stangenschloss. Das reicht bei mir völlig aus. Die Tür ist innen hohe. Die Tür ist noch eine ganz alte Tür aus der Vorkriegszeit. Es ist aber auch nicht wichtig in der Wohnung.
Das Stangenschloss ist definitiv über dem Durchschnitt.
Was heißt das? Entschuldigung, was ist ein Stangenschloss?
Ein Stangenschloss ist ein Schloss mit einer Stange nach oben und nach unten. Ganz besonders gut bei zwei oder mehr flügeligen Türen.
Diese sind dann in einem Rahmen oder sogar an der Wand arretiert. Privatstatistik aus meinem Freundeskreis ist, es haben vor allem die Wohnungen, wo schon mal eingebrochen wurde.
Oder wo man weiß, was für Türen sind. Aus Pappe, die in so riesen Leerfelder haben, die man eigentlich vollfüllen müsste. Wenn man mal Regen stolpert gegen die Tür, ist man durch die Tür durchgefallen.
Alles klar, Andy, sehr schön, flüssiger Stickstoff haben wir noch eine Möglichkeit. Gibt es noch andere Chemikalien, die man zum Türöffnen benutzen kann?
Nein, nicht Chemikalien. Da gibt es ja immer noch die Feuerwehr-Variante.
Die ist aber dann mit einem großen Hammer die Tür aufmachen, oder?
Nein, ein langes Brecheisen. Auf dem Rückweg des Einsatzes ziehen sie das klassischerweise hinter sich her. Das ist so ein langes Eisen, zwei Meter lang, deutlich schwer. Und damit rennen sie einfach auf die Tür zu, hauen auf Höhe des Schlosses zwischen Tür und Rahmen. Und dann sind die meisten Türen offen.
Das ist dann aber einfach pure Gewalt.
Ja, weil es brennt, muss schnell gehen. Die haben keine Zeit, eine Stunde, keine Schlossung.
Ist schon klar, aber ich kann dir sagen, das ist irgendein physikalter Trick mit Hebelwirken. Nein, das ist einfach nur pure Gewalt. Um noch mal ganz kurz auf die Karte zurückzukommen, weil wir über verschiedene Materialien gesprochen haben. Ich habe mal gehört, das Material von Plaste, Getränke, Cola, irgendwas, Flaschen eignet sich da sehr gut. Wenn es mal schnell geht, muss man nichts zur Hand hat. Ist da was dran? Nein?
Doch? Habe ich noch nie gehört, kann ich mir aber vorstellen.
Habe ich auch schon gehört und funktioniert auch ganz gut.
Also die Materialanforderungen sind quasi flexibel und gleichzeitig stabil.
Wo wir bei Materialien sind, bei dem Draht, da gibt es auch so zwei Klassiker. Das eine sind Fahrradspeichen und das andere sind die Metallstreifen im Scheibenwischer.
Ja oder noch eine Alternative, die von den Straßenkehrmaschinen, von den Bürsten, die Borsten sind auch so lange Stahldinger. Die sind auch sehr geeignet.
Ja, aber es stehen mehr Autos und Fahrräder rum.
Das ist richtig.
Entschuldigt Leute, ihr sollt nicht von anderen Fahrrädern und von anderen Autos die dünnen Drähte da, ja? Das ist wie mit der Tür, nur eure eigene.
Wenn man die Nachbarn fragt, kann man sich das ja borgen und die mal ein neues kaufen.
Nachbar kann ich mir mal eine Fahrradspeiche von dir borgen. Ich glaube, das könnte zur Verwirrung führen. Aber gut, über die mechanischen Schlösser haben wir jetzt ganz viel geredet, also über die Türschlösser vor allem. Ich möchte jetzt gerne zu einem anderen Punkt kommen. Erst mal möchte ich sagen, ruft an. 0331 70 97 120 mit euren Schlossgeschichten. Es ist schon irgendwie ein oder zwei Leute gab's, die zwischendurch aufgelegt haben. Müsst ihr nicht, ihr müsst ein bisschen Geduld haben, aber ihr kommt auf jeden Fall dran. Ich würde jetzt noch mal auf den Daumen zu sprechen kommen. Den Daumabdruck, bzw. den Fingerabdruck, mit dem man auch ein Schloss sichern kann. Wie sicher das ist?
Also Fingerabdrücke sind generell eine ziemlich bescheuerte Idee. Es geht damit los, dass bei einigen Schlössern, man kennt das vielleicht aus einem schlechten Film, da ist so ein Fingerabdrucksensor und dann kommt James Bond und haucht so ein bisschen auf den Sensor drauf und dann sieht man den Fingerabdruck wieder und dann macht er irgendwie so ein bisschen Vuvu und dann geht die Tür auf. Das funktioniert bei manchen wirklich.
Entschuldigung, wie? Ist das auch auf das Schloss drauf?
Ja, du hinterlässt doch Fingerabdrücke. Wenn du irgendwie mit deinem Finger irgendwo hintaschst, dann hast du einen Fingerabdruck, der sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass an den Stellen, wo dein Finger so ein bisschen eine Erhöhung hat, Fett kleben bleibt und an der Vertiefung klebt hat, kein Fett. Und dem Moment, wo du dahin hauchst, kondensiert das Wasser nur an der Stelle, wo kein Fett ist. Und dann entsteht ein Bild des Fingerabdrucks. Und es gibt tatsächlich Sensoren, die sind so billig, dass das ausreicht und dann sagt das Ding, ja klar, ist der richtige Finger. Also ist dann auch schon gleich der passende Finger, der das Schloss aufmacht, auf dem Schloss drauf. Also großartig.
Also am besten finde ich da Fingerabdruckscanner an Laptops, die ja voll Fingerabdrücke sind.
Besonders mit dem neuen Trend, wo nicht nur die Displays, sondern auch die Deckel in Klavierlack-Optik ausgeführt werden.
Also bei anderen ist es schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Es gibt da verschiedene Techniken. Unter anderem, also entweder optisch, optisch haben wir gerade gehabt, das ist scheiße, wenn man einfach bloß ein Bild macht, kann man dann auch ein Bild von einem Fingerabdruck drüber halten, das geht dann auch. Die etwas besseren funktionieren kapazitiv. Also die erkennen sozusagen, wo eine Berührung auf dem Sensor ist. Muss man sich so vorstellen wie ein Kamerasensor, nur dass man direkt auf den nackten Sensor drauf fasst und da wo man ihn berührt, also da wo wieder die Erhöhung im Fingerabdruck ist, ist die Kapazität an der Stelle anders und dann kann man das da rausjagen und irgendwie ein Bild des Fingerabdrucks erstellen.
Also kapazitiv ist, ist quasi sowas wie eine Art Smartphone Display.
Genau, nur viel feiner aufgelöst. Also eigentlich wie wenn man seine Digitalkamera aufmacht und direkt auf den Sensor fasst.
Das könnt ihr ja noch mal probieren.
Technisch nahezu dasselbe. Und da muss man schon ein bisschen mehr Aufwand treiben. Da muss man nämlich eine 3D-Struktur nachbauen. Wie macht man das? Wie macht man das? Wir sind dann drauf gekommen, als wir da mal drum gebastelt haben, auf eine Folie mit einem Laserdrucker ein Bild von dem Fingerabdruck auszudrucken. Und dann setzt sich die Druckerschwärze auf der Folie ab und steht so ein bisschen über. Und dann kann man mit ein bisschen Holzkaltleim eine Schicht darüber machen, warten bis es fest ist und das dann abziehen. Und dann hat man einen Holzkaltleim mit einer 3D-Struktur drin.
Und der leitet dann auch für das Kapazitive?
Ja, wenn der nicht ausreichend leitet, muss man ein bisschen mit Grafitpulver rumspielen. Aber bei den meisten Sensoren geht es einfach so. Ja, das geht dann auch. Und bei den richtig tollen gibt es dann eine Lebenderkennung. Da steckt man also seinen Finger rein. Und dann kommen die mit Infrarotlicht und sehen da die Venen. Und dann müssen dann die Venen pulsieren, damit das alles funktioniert. Und bei den wirklich guten messen sie nach, wo die Venen sind. Aber so wirklich gute sind glaube ich auch gar nicht wirklich erhältlich am Markt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die schon wirklich verkauft werden. Die nicht ganz so guten mit Lebenderkennung, da tut man dann einfach, nachdem man sich also dieses mit seinem Holzkaltleim den Fingerabdruck gemacht hat, sich dünn auf seinen Finger draufkleben. Dann steckt man ja einen echten Finger mit dem gesuchten Fingerabdruck rein. Und die Lebenderkennung sagt, ja, er steckt ein echter Finger drin. Und das ist auch der richtige Fingerabdruck. Und dann geht's auf.
Ich find's wirklich sehr schön. Aber sieh man das vorhin, das klang so, als ob du... Du meintest irgendwie so, ja Fingerabdrücke, da gibt's auch sozusagen gute und schlechte Sachen. Und es klang so, als ob du schon das auch für Plausibilheit anzuwenden, in bestimmten Fällen.
Na, es kommt immer drauf an, was man damit schützen will. Andreas hat ja jetzt nur viele Facetten erzählt. Und es geht halt von sehr einfachen und teilweise auch günstigen Lösungen bis zu schon sehr anspruchsvollen Lösungen. Und es ist, soweit ich informiert bin, auch eine Frage, wie in Anführungsstrichen die Auflösung ist. Das heißt, wie viele Merkmale abgefragt werden oder eingescannt werden. Und das hat einfach was mit der Praxistauglichkeit zu tun. Umso genauer das ist, umso höher ist die Fehlerquote.
Also auch, wenn der eigentliche Besitzer des Fingers da reinlegt, dann wird trotzdem ein Anarm heisst.
Also man hat die Herdplatte gefasst und dann ist ein Stückchen von deinem Fingerabdruck weg, geht die Tür nicht mehr auf.
Richtig. Und auch wie gerade man den Finger rauflegt, da sind manche Systeme auch toleranter oder intolerant. Und umso toleranter die sind, umso größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein anderer seinen Finger drauf legt und es aufgeht.
Also ich halte mal fest, ich hatte anfangs die Frage gestellt, dass ich bei so einem In the Cloud Service Host da auf einer Webseite war, der gesagt hat, ja unsere Server sind gesichert. Da ist dann ein Biometrie-Dingens dran, also ein Fingerabdruckscanner. Das heißt, im Prinzip hat in seiner Werbung geschrieben, wir sind Schloss dran. Das sagt also über die Qualität erst mal noch überhaupt gar nichts.
Genau und irgendwie, also wenn sie explizit Fingerabdrücke geschrieben haben, auch ähnlich besonders gut ist. Mittlerweile habe ich neulich gelesen, gibt es Kameras, die gar nicht mal so groß sind, mit denen man den Fingerabdruck aus mehreren Metern Entfernung einfach vom Finger abfotografieren kann. Ja, da musst du gar nicht mal irgendwie irgendjemanden sein Wasserglas vom Podium klauen, um an den Fingerabdruck ranzukommen, sondern es reicht einfach aus, ein Foto zu machen. Und andere Systeme, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja noch Iris Scanner, wo also ein Bild des Auges gemacht wird, da ist natürlich genau das selbe Problem, dass man mit einem Teleobjektiv aus großem Abstand einfach knips. Und sich die Daten klauen kann. Dass man das Zugangsmerkmal überall hinterlässt, ist meines Erachtens das größte Problem bei den Fingerabdrücken.
Es gibt den generell, ohne in die Biometrie-Diskussionen abgleiten zu wollen, aber gibt es eine Art Schließsystem, die über biometrische, also irgendeine Körperteilerkennungserfassung funktioniert, wo ihr sagt, da könnte noch was raus werden?
Es gibt einen, der funktioniert, der ist aber ganz schön schmerzhaft für den Benutzer. Und zwar ist das eine, die Netzhauterkennung. Also wird einem mit einem hellen Licht ins Auge geleuchtet. Wenn man schon beim Augenarzt war, kennt man das.
Ach, das gibt es tatsächlich. Ich hab ja nur so einen Film gesehen, wo so ein Flash kommt, und dann wird irgendwie ein Foto von einem Herz bekommen.
Das gibt es tatsächlich. Und sie nehmen es tatsächlich auch hauptsächlich für Atombunker und so ein Scheiß, weil es irgendwie, also die Nutzerakzeptanz ist grauenhaft, weil man möchte einfach nicht zweimal am Tag mit einem echt hellen Licht ins Auge geleuchtet bekommen. So, aber das ist wirklich gut, weil da kommt man auch schwer ran.
Aber das ist trotzdem sozusagen ein bildgebendes Verfahren.
Aber es ist halt ein Merkmal, was man nicht jeden Tag mit sich rumträgt. Also wie oft kommt jemand auf dich zu und guckt dir genau auf deine Netzhaut.
Kommt drauf an, wie komische Leute du kennst. Aber gut, ich verstehe schon.
Alles klar ist. In dem Bereich muss man sich natürlich auch Gedanken machen, wer im Nachts auflauert und dann mit seinem Auge wegläuft.
Dann möchte ich ja gerade mal das Thema wieder ändern, und zwar mit Jürgen, der hier am Telefon ist, der eine Frage hat, die ich interessant finde und gar nicht selber drauf gekommen bin. Jürgen? Deine Frage ist?
Ja, meine Frage ist, ich meine, wir sind jetzt schon vom Elementaren weg. Ihr seid jetzt schon in höheren Szenen. Aber mich würde mal interessieren, wie Behörden und was weiß ich, welche Institute noch mit Generalschlüssen umgehen, wie das funktioniert. Ich meine, das ist ja nun nicht mehr mit Schlüsten, oder?
Doch, also auch. Also Generalschlüsse, es gibt ja so Volksweisheiten, dass es für jeden Schloss einen Generalschlüssel gibt. Das ist definitiv nicht so. Generalschlüssel werden gerade in größeren Anlagen, wo man sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Schließungen bewerkstellen muss, mit unterschiedlichen Merkmalen umgesetzt. Das ist einmal das Profil des Schlüssels. Also ein einfacher Zimmertürschlüssel ist sehr breit und hat einen sehr breiten Schaft- oder Schließkanal, wo man den Schlüssel reinsteckt. Und der General-Schlüssel ist sehr viel schmaler und zierlicher, sodass er in mehrere verschiedene Profile reinpasst. Der einzelne Zimmerschlüssel, der dicke, passt aber vielleicht drei Türen weiter schon nicht mal mehr ins Schloss, sodass man an diesem Schloss immer gleiche Stifte für eine andere Schließberechtigung vergeben kann. Und dann ist es außerdem so, dass in so einem klassischen Stiftzylinder dann mit sogenannten Plättchen gearbeitet wird. Also da hat man nicht nur ein Kernstift und ein Gehäuse-Stift, sondern dazwischen auch noch ein Plättchen, sodass man an zwei unterschiedlichen Stellen, also mit zwei verschiedenen Schlüsseln schließen kann.
Links und rechts. Also ich meine, dass man links und rechts dann kontaktiert.
Nee, das ist so, dass man sich das so vorstellen kann, dass die Schlüssel, da sind ja die Nasen verschieden weit reingesägt. Ein bisschen weiter, ein bisschen weniger weit. Und dadurch, dass man also nicht nur zwei Stifte hat, sondern noch so ein bisschen was dazwischen, funktioniert der eine Schlüssel, der ein bisschen weiter reingefriesst. Es sind der andere, der nicht ganz so weit reingefriesst. Es funktioniert auch. Und das kann man halt an zwei, drei Stellen machen. Und damit kann man sich dann Systeme bauen, wo ein Schlüssel bei allen Schlössern passt und ein anderer nur bei einigen, und der dritte nur bei genau einem Schloss. Das macht natürlich auch das Picken einfacher. Man hat mehr Möglichkeiten, wie man den Stift bewegen kann.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist im Prinzip ein Spiel mit den Toleranzen.
Ja, also definitiv ja. Aber irgendwo muss man ja das Ganze auch praxistauglich machen. Trotzdem ist die Tür verschlossen. Da ist wieder der Punkt, wo ich sage, man muss mal abwägen, was will man damit machen. Man kann ja an besonders wichtigen Türen auch ein zweites Schloss anbringen. Aber das kommt jetzt erstmal von einer eigentlichen Frage ab. Wie gesagt, bei diesen Plättchen, das kann man nicht nur in einem Stift machen, sondern in mehreren Stiften. Dann hat man schon sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wenn jetzt hier jemand die Befugnis hat, ins Haus rein zu kommen, also jetzt spricht Miethaus, dass der auch mit dem Generalschlüssel in die Wohnung kann.
Das ist in der Regel so. Auch in Wohnhäusern kann das so sein, dass es einen Generalschlüssel gibt. Dann sollte das aber im Mietvertrag drinstehen, dass der Vermieter einen Schlüssel zu deiner Wohnung hat. Im Mietbereich ist es klassischerweise so, dass man da einen sogenannten technischen Hauptschlüssel hat. Der schließt dann alle nicht privaten Räume. Also die Wohnungstüren werden dann wirklich nur von dem Wohnungsschlüssel geschlossen. Und der technische Hauptschlüssel schließt dann sowas wie Hauseingangstür, Hoftür, Kellertür, Hausanschlussraum und so weiter.
Mit anderen Wochen kann ich dann auch zu meiner Wohnungsbau-Gewätschaft gehen, wenn meine Tür zugeschlagen ist ohne, dass ich wieder reinkomme, dass die mir eine Generalsicherung wieder aufmachen.
Wenn sie so einen haben.
Meistens nicht.
Ja, aber das wäre doch, ich meine, würde doch mietvorm Mieter freundlich sein, ne?
Boah, also, das tänkt immer so ein bisschen vom Vermieter ab. Und was man so für ein Verhältnis zum hat. Also ich kenn schon Geschichten von Leuten, die dann angefangen haben an ihren Schnapsflaschen mit Bleistiftmarkierungen zu machen, weil der Vermieter immer saufen gekommen ist. Und ich zum Beispiel baue mir grundsätzlich, wenn ich irgendwo in eine Mietwohnung ziehe, erstmal meinen eigenen Zylinder ein. Und wenn ich ausziehe, kriegt der Vermieter sein wieder. Weil steht er zwar, dass er keinen Schlüssel mehr hat, aber eigentlich möchte ich nicht, dass der mich besucht, ohne dass ich das weiß.
Gerne, Jürgen, und viel Spaß und ein sicheres Wissen.
Ja, ich hatte deinem Vorzimmermensch schon noch gesagt, weil ich das so wunderbar finde. Deine Lache, wenn die mal Junge kriegt, möchte ich gerne ein.
Um Gottes Willen, jetzt kommen wir aber in Bereiche, wo ich ganz unangenehm berührt werde und auch gleich mal auflegen muss. Jürgen, vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. So, jetzt sind wir beim Generalschüssel, Biometrie, Türen, was fehlt noch? Also, mein Autos fehlen eigentlich noch, oder?
Autos, Autos ist eine gute Sache.
Das Schönste, was ich ja neulich über Autos gelesen hab, ist... Ah nee, erzähl die erst mal.
Autos sind Wegversperren, ne?
Autos sind Wegversperren, ja.
Ist glaub ich gerade wieder zum Problem geworden. Die Diebstahlzahlen bei BMW sind wieder hochgegangen und sie müssen da jetzt mal wieder was tun. Ich muss zugeben, ich hab mich nicht im Detail mit beschäftigt. Aber das Spannende ist, dass viele von diesen Dingern ja über Funk funktionieren und einfach über die Nähe. Und dass es offensichtlich mittlerweile Leute gibt, die sich sozusagen in Anführungszeichen eine Funkverlängerung bauen. Das heißt, der eine steht bei dem Auto, der andere setzt sich dann im Restaurant unauffällig nebenan und hält es in die Nähe des Schlüssels. Und dann macht es einmal Klick und dann ist das Auto da draußen offen und auch die Schließanlage.
Naja, also man muss da ja auch unterscheiden. Es gibt ja ja verschiedene Dinge. Ganz klassisch hat es ja vor einiger Zeit erst angefangen, dass man immer noch mechanische Schlüssel hatte und dann irgendwie eine Wegfahrsperre, weil dann die Versicherungen das irgendwann wollten. Dass man also mit dem Schlüssel ganz normal die Tür aufschließt, mit dem Schlüssel ganz normal das Zündschloss bestätigt und dann ist da noch so ein ganz kleiner RFID-Transponder drin, der dann irgendwie mit dem Auto kommuniziert und das schaltet dann irgendwie auf magische Weise innerhalb der Motorsteuerung die Wegfahrsperre frei, damit man auch losfahren kann.
Funktioniert genauso wie ein Kopierschutz bei Spielen. Funktioniert auch genauso gut wie ein Kopierschutz bei Spielen.
Es kommt auf die Implementierung an.
Also ich habe genau das nämlich auch gelesen mit diesem, wir bauen uns eine Fernbedienung, die tatsächlich Autos dienen.
Das war jetzt halt, wenn man mit dem klassischen Schlüssel aufschließt, dann gab es dann irgendwann später die Fernbedienung. Da gibt es dann auch wieder verschiedene Varianten, einfach so klassisch eine Fernbedienung, die dann einen Code aussendet oder eine Fernbedienung mit dem Auto redet und die unterhalten sich dann untereinander. Da ist zum Beispiel schon seit längerer Zeit eine beliebte Angriffsmethode, dass man einfach Leute anguckt auf dem Parkplatz, wenn sie losgehen und auf ihre Fernbedienung drücken und das Auto zu schließen wollen. Dass man einfach mit irgendeinem Störsender dazwischen sendet und dann schließt das Auto nicht ab und der Mensch geht einfach los. Dann ist das Auto immer noch offen. Das war zum Beispiel lange Zeit noch sehr beliebt. Man muss also immer gucken, auch wenn man auf den Knopf gedrückt hat, ist das Auto wirklich zugegangen. Und neuerdings gibt es halt nicht einfach nur mehr Fernbedienung, schließt Auto auf, ein zweiter Transponder schaltet die Wegfahrsperre frei, sondern es gibt mittlerweile sogar Systeme. Das nennt sich dann Keyless Entry. Da sind sie jetzt alle ganz stolz drauf, auch bei BMW. Da geht das Auto einfach auf, sobald man sich innerhalb von ungefähr zwei Meter Entfernung vom Auto befindet. Also wenn man den Schlüssel in zwei Meter Entfernung vom Auto hat, geht das Auto auf und dann hat man auch keinen Zündschloss mehr, sondern es gibt bloß noch einen Startknopf, der einfach auch nur funktioniert, wenn der Schlüssel sich innerhalb von zwei Meter Entfernung befindet. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, selbst wenn man als Laie sich so ein System anguckt und überlegt, das braucht eine Funkentfernung von zwei Metern. Und Funks sind ja auch einfach bloß irgendwelche Datensignale. Datensignale kann man weiterleiten. Das bedeutet also nicht einfach nur, dass sich das Auto in zwei Meter Entfernung befinden muss, sondern im Zweifelsfall einfach nur der Empfänger des Angreifers befindet sich in zwei Meter Entfernung von dir. Das sind wahrscheinlich häufiger mal viele Menschen. Und der hat dann einen Komplizen, der mit dem Sender zum Auto geht.
Das war ja noch nicht immer so. Also früher musste man ja immer noch auf den Knopf drücken, damit das aufgegangen ist. Und so die vermeintliche Vereinfachung für den Kunden war, man muss gar nicht mehr zum Schlüsselgreifen auf den Knopf drücken, dass es aufgeht. Und das macht natürlich das Risiko aus, weil wenn man einfach auf den Knopf drücken müsste, wenn man in der Kneipe sitzt, damit der Angreifer inzwischen das Auto klopft. Aber Ding einfach ein bisschen.
Na ja, es gibt auch Leute, die als nervösend ticken mit dem Knopf spielen.
Ja, das ist eher selten.
Also mein Part ist ja der mechanische. Und bei diesen Systemen kann ja auch mal die Batterie alle sein. Deswegen haben ja alle noch meistens in diesem Schlüssel versteckt so ein Notschlüssel.
Irgendwo hinter dem Logo oder so, wenn man mal so ein System hat. Genau.
Hinter dem Logo, ja. Ich werde jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber bei deutschen Oberklasseautos kann man auch Autos kaufen, die so 80 bis 100.000 Euro kosten. Und wo es klassisch theoretisch mögliche verschiedene Schlüssel 16 Stück gibt, von denen aber nicht alle benutzt werden. Das heißt, dass Oberklasseautos ausgeliefert werden, so mit acht verschiedenen Schließungen, die man ja mal bei haben kann und ausprobieren kann in unter einer Minute.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Du hast acht Schlüssel bei und schließt garantiert auf.
Das ist wie bei den Schreibtischschlössern, weißt du? Wenn deiner nicht passt, dann passt der vom Nachbarn, weil mehr Sorten Schlüssel gibt es gar nicht.
Für alle Autos dieses Types gibt es acht verschiedene Schlüssel und die werden einfach so sagen, willkürlich verteilt.
Genau.
Entschuldigung.
Und dafür bezahlt man richtig viel Geld.
Und das hat denn noch keiner gesagt? Also bzw. hat keiner gesagt, so wir haben das mitgekriegt. Könnte das mal ändern oder?
Das interessiert die Leute nicht.
Tja, das erklärt vielleicht auch die hohen Liesperrsraten in diesem Bereich. Okay, das ist ein urbaner Mythos, den ich mal gehört habe. Nämlich dieses jemand wettet mit jemand, dass er genau so ein Auto irgendwie schnell aufmacht. Und dann legt er einfach eine brennende Zeitung drunter. Und dann geht irgendwie so eine Not hier. Alle Passagiere müssen aus dem Auto raus können. Deswegen geht das Auto auf. Gibt es so eine Tricks auch? Also quasi, dass man sagt, dass man nicht den Schlüssel hackt?
Habe ich noch nicht von gehört, kann ich mir aber lebhaft vorstellen. Also solche Autos, da passiert ja einiges, wenn so ein Unfall passiert. Dann muss ja dann der Airbag ausgelöst werden. Dann müssen bestimmte Sachen ausgeschaltet werden, von links nach rechts gefahren, wegen der Sicherheit und so. Und wenn das Auto einen Unfall feststellt, ist auch die Tür entriegelt, damit man im Zweifelsfall rauskommt. Halte dich für plausibel. Also wenn man dem Auto vermittelt, du, da ist gerade ein Unfall, dann macht er bestimmt die Tür auf.
Also das ist definitiv so. Also bei Autos, wo die Airbags auslösen und die Systeme haben, die beim Losfahren, selbst verriegeln, im Unfallfall entriegeln die. Allerdings hatte ich von der Rauchmelder Version nicht gehört.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein Ding, das habe ich gehört, als es jemand erzählt hat von jemand, dessen Freundin, der Schipschwager und so. Das ging mir jetzt nur um diese Art des Angriffs. Also das hat gar nichts mit dem Schloss zu tun, sondern bringt das Auto irgendwie dazu, zu glauben, ich muss jetzt mal die Türen aufmachen.
Kommt sicher auch das Auto an.
Das kannte ich noch nicht, finde ich aber gut.
Könnte beim Oberklasseauto sein, wenn man so wie ich ein Auto hat, was elektronisch ein Licht, ein Blinker und ein Autoradio hat und sonst nichts, da würde es wohl nicht funktionieren.
Dein Auto hat Elektronik, mein es hat Elektrik.
Elektrik.
Jetzt geht es aber ins Detail. Ist es Absicht oder ist es einfach nur alt?
Nein, es ist einfach nur alt. Aber zu Autos wollte ich noch ein paar Geschichten erzählen. Früher sehr beliebt war die Nummer mit dem Tennisball. Und man hat ja bei Autos immer diesen Hebel, den man runterdrücken kann, wieder rausziehen kann. Je nachdem, wie das Schloss gebaut ist, gibt es einige. Dann nimmt man sich einen Tennisball, dann macht man ein kleines Loch rein. Das setzt man auf das Schloss drauf, dann haut man drauf. Dann entsteht in dem Schloss ein Überdruck und dann wird der Stift nach oben gedrückt, plopp, und dann ist die Tür offen.
Das ist ja cool. Ich hab es tatsächlich mal geschafft. Da war ich auch wirklich stolz drauf. Typische Situation, Schlüssel im Auto vergessen, Regelung zugemacht, Auto zugeworfen. Oh Gott, was jetzt? Ja, wir haben doch mal im Film gesehen, irgendwie mit Radbügeln. Haben wir tatsächlich sozusagen so einen alten Bügel genommen und den irgendwie oben durch die Tür rein gefrickelt und dann mit diesem Knopf hochgezogen.
Das macht man auch tatsächlich professionell teilweise so. Also die Profis haben dann noch einen kleinen Keil dabei mit einer Gummiumwandlung, der oben in die Tür reingetrieben wird, damit man auch Platz hat, um reinzukommen. Wieder die Geschichte mit den Toleranzen, aber total gängige Methode.
Das andere Problem ist, dass heute ja niemand mehr etwas sieht. Als ich in dem Job angefangen hab, ging es auch irgendwann mal darum, Autos zu öffnen. Dann sind wir rausgegangen auf die Straße und haben mein Auto aufgebrochen. Und da sind die Leute vorbeigelaufen, die haben uns nicht angesprochen. Also wir standen da in Zivil und haben Auto aufgemacht, wieder zugemacht, Auto aufgemacht, wieder zugemacht, Auto. Und die Leute gehen vorbei und weiter und da sagt keiner was.
Also bei uns kam tatsächlich dann, nach 20 Minuten, einer halben Stunde kam tatsächlich die Polizei. Wir hatten die Papiere natürlich in den Wagen drin, aber die haben dann ganz entspannt gewartet, bis wir das aufgekriegt haben. Haben allerdings auch nicht geholfen. Dürfen die wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht.
Aber dazu eine Anekdote, eine Bekannte von mir, fuhr in einen Berliner Bezirk und steigt aus, macht das Auto zu, Schlüssel liegt drin. Da kommen so drei Jugendliche auf sie zu und sagen so, was ist denn? Ich hab meinen Schlüssel drin vergessen, ja. Und dann meint sie, ach kein Problem, macht die Jacke auf, zack zack, Auto offen.
Tatsächlich?
Sie hat dann umgeparkt.
Was ich auch mal gesehen habe, auch bei Freunden, wir waren unterwegs, kommen wieder, plötzlich irgendwie Sachen aus dem Auto geklaut, aber Auto abgeschlossen. Alles angeguckt, alles angeguckt. Irgendwann haben wir festgestellt, am Türgummi an einer Stelle war ein kleines Loch drin. Und das war so eins der ersten Autos, die eine Zentralverriegelung hatten. Da war dann an der Seite im Türgriff der Knopf zum Fähr und Entriegeln. Da reicht es offensichtlich aus, mit einer ausreichend langen Speiche von oben durch den Türgummi durch auf den Knopf zu drücken, dann hat das Auto die Tür aufgemacht.
Wie großartig. Mir ist das auch mal passiert. Allerdings war das eine Ente und da haben sie einfach die Fenster aufgeschraubt. Ja, das fand ich. Bei der Ente geht das. Ich meine, das ist eine Ente. Das ist halt ein Stück Blech mit einem Motor drin. Aber es ist liebenswert. Und da einzubrechen. Na gut, da kann ich mich jetzt schon lange echauffieren, das müssen wir aber nicht machen. Was eigentlich in der Rubrik noch fehlt, also Türschlösser, Autoschlösser, sind noch Fahrradschlösser, oder? Gibt es da was zu sagen, was wir nicht sowieso schon hatten?
Bolzenschneider.
Ja, na da gibt es auch die etwas besseren Fahrradschlösser, da geht das dann nicht so einfach mit dem Bolzenschneider, die kosten aber auch viel Geld.
Da nimmt man einen Kabelschneider. Also Kabelschneider, die so 100er Telefonkabel durchschneiden, schneiden auch jedes Fahrradschloss durch.
Was ist 100er Telefonkabel?
Also so mit 100 Kupferdoppeladern, auch die muss man irgendwie durchschneiden und sowas gibt es auch so mechanisch zum Ratschen, was so auch nicht größer als ein Jackenärmel ist.
Und die, da kommst du durch jedes Fahrradschloss mit durch, sagst du?
Ja, ja. Ich hab letztens einen Kunden gehabt, der hatte bei mir ein sehr hochwertiges Schloss gekauft, muss ich dazu sagen. Und der kam dann an und es war richtig sauber, glatt durchgeschnitten. Und das war nicht mit einem Bolzenschneider gemacht, weil beim Bolzenschneider hat man so Quetschungen. Und es gibt halt, danach haben wir lange recherchiert, und es gibt halt Kabelschneider, die man halt auch ohne Gewerbe in die Näme kaufen kann. Und die schneiden so ziemlich alles durch. Also so auch bis richtige Durchmesser. So richtig traurig.
Es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit diese Schlösser, die man so zusammenfalten kann, diese aus einzelnen Metallstücken bestehen. Und hat mal jemand Sekundenkleber ins Schloss gesprüht, das fand ich total großartig. Mit dem Fahrradladen hat das einfach aufgeflext. Das hat halt auch noch drei Minuten gedauert, aber war natürlich ziemlich laut.
Macht richtig Krach. Und es gibt auch nur wenige sehr richtig teure Akku-Flexen. Also man hat selten so Strom dabei. Flex ist total klasse, aber Flex braucht immer richtig Strom.
Es ist eine blöde Idee, also Steckdosen vor der Tür zu haben oder da, wo man seinen Fahrradschluss steckt, ein richtig doofes Ding. Muss man sagen.
Naja, aber das Ding ist ja, man braucht es auch nicht mehr, weil es gibt ja diese Kabelschneider. Wie teuer sind die?
Keine Information. Also da gibt es sicher auch bessere und schlechte.
Wäre natürlich die Frage überhaupt, wie teuer oder billiger als eine Flex sind.
Eine Akku-Flex wohlgemerkt. Fahrräder machen sowieso nicht so viel Spaß, weil Fahrräder haben ja schon seit längerer Zeit eine Rahmennummer, die eindeutig identifizierbar ist. Aber was gerade in so kinderbeliebten Bezirken wie Prenzlauer Berg ein großes Problem ist, sind Kinderwagen. Weil Kinderwagen, dafür geben die Leute richtig Geld aus. Also so für gute Kinderwagen 500 bis 3000 Euro. Ja, es ist keine Seltenheit. Und selbst wenn man mal so im Second Hand Laden vorbeigeht und da schon richtig ramponierte Kinderwagen sieht man selten im zweistelligen Bereich. Und da gibt es richtig organisierte Gruppen. Und Leute schließen ihre Kinderwagen teilweise mit deutlich besserer Technik als Fahrräder an, weil sie sind einfach nicht registriert, haben keine Rahmennummer, können überall verkauft werden. Das ist ein echtes Problem zurzeit.
Kinderwagen, die das aber moralisch schon ganz schön verkommen, oder?
Das war so schlimm wie eine Ente aufbrechen.
Gibt es noch Moral?
Das ist eine Frage, die auch die klingeln wie in einer anderen Sendung. Überhaupt machen wir jetzt erst mal eine kurze Pause, weil das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, wieder auf uns wartet und danach geht es weiter. Heute ist Chaos Radio, das 164. halbe Stunde haben wir noch und der Typ, der seinen Rechner gerade auf dem Pult des Nachrichtmanns hatte stehen lassen, ist Andreas vom Chaos Computer Club.
Ich bin Ikke.
So sieht es aus. Außerdem ist Henrik da. Und als Mann vom Fach der Simon. Hallo zurück. Es geht heute noch eine halbe Stunde um Schließsachen. Also wir haben schon über Türen gesprochen, über Schlösser, über wie die Tür selber aussehen muss, über Elektronik, die bei Türen mit am Start ist, über Autos, über Fahrradschlösser und jetzt haben wir noch zwei Anrufer. Mal gucken, was die noch dazu beizutragen haben. Da ist erstens der Paul. Hallo Paul. Na, hast du eine Tür aufgemacht oder ist die Tür zugegangen?
Ja, sie ist eine Zugang. Wir haben sie aufgemacht. Das war unsere alte Tür bei meinen Eltern. Die war so ein bisschen älter und da gab es zwischen Tür und Türrahmen so einen halben Zentimeter Platz. Und mit jedem bisschen stabileren Gegenstand konnten wir die relativ leicht aufmachen. Also Schraubenzieher haben wir benutzt, Spaten, Wasserwäsche, Klammer, eigentlich so alles.
Das heißt, ihr habt keinen Schlüssel mehr dabei gehabt, sondern ihr habt einfach immer so einen als Sport gemacht.
Nicht wirklich. Also man hat ja die Schlüssel eher draußen drin vergessen. Und dann muss man ja irgendwie wieder reinkommen und irgendwo zu Bekannten laufen und Schlüssel holen war irgendwie scheiße. Deswegen, na ja, in den Schuppen gegangen, irgendwie das nächste Beste genommen. Und dann eine halbe Minute später nicht mal war die Tür offen.
Aber bei euch eingebrochen ist nicht mal geworden?
Doch einmal, aber das war, da haben sie das Fenster eingeworfen.
Ja, blöd meiner Eier, hätte doch einfach durch die Tür gehen können.
Richtig, richtig.
Na gut, die war zu dem Zeitpunkt abgeschlossen. Also das durfte sie nicht sein. Also abgeschlossen durfte sie nicht sein, aber ansonsten.
Halber Zertimeter nicht schlecht. Und hast du dann, seitdem ist dir das egal oder achtest du jetzt ein bisschen mehr darauf, dass die Tür ein bisschen enger schließt?
Nö, wir haben jetzt ein neuer und das geht jetzt. Also Kumpel von mir, der ist dann irgendwie ab und zu, wenn meine Eltern nicht da waren, auch gekommen. Und ich wohne hier, war am oberen Stoffler, Klinge ist kaputt gewesen und naja, dann ist einfach, hat immer eine Straubenzieher dabei, damit er reinkommt.
Nicht schlecht.
Da muss man den Schlüssel nicht mehr unten draußen vorm Stein verstecken.
Richtig.
Also gerade bei Haustünen ist die Toleranz immer Wahnsinn.
Weil die so abgenutzt sind? Also ist das sagen, ist das eingebaut?
Ja, Wetter, schwer, groß, wackelig, kümmert sich auch manchmal keiner drum. Also es gibt ja Müllkutscher, die ja eigentlich immer einen Schlüssel haben, die einfach eine Karte haben, weil es schneller geht, als den Schlüssel rauszusuchen. Habe ich schon gesehen.
Ich mache das. Ich habe, Paul, erstmal vielen Dank für deine Haustür und viel Spaß damit noch. Danke. Bei uns an der Haustür ist neben der Tür ein Schloss in die Wand eingelassen und wir haben ein Sommer. Hat das irgendwas mit Müllmännern, Postkutschern oder irgendwas zu tun?
Das Schloss an der Wand ist die Feuerwehr.
Es ist meistens ein kleines rundes Röhrchen, so genannter Schlüsseltresor und da ist so eine Standardschließung der Feuerwehr drinne, meistens der lokalen Feuerwehr und da liegt dann ein Schlüssel von der Haustür, von der Kellertür, wahrscheinlich von den Anschlussräumen drinne. Eventuell auch von deiner Wohnung.
Na klar, die müssen überleeren, aber sie sagen, da kommt nur die Feuerwehr ran.
Oder ein Lockpicker.
Ja, ok, das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen. Mann, ihr könnt ja nicht gleich alles wegnehmen. Also gedacht ist es, dass nur die Feuerwehr ran kommt und nicht die Post oder sozusagen die Müllmänner irgendwie dafür auch Schlüssel haben.
Die Post hat eigene Schlüsselfächer.
Wie? Auch jetzt für das Haus oder wie?
Für die Haustür zumindest. Die müssen ja an den Briefkasten rankommen. Du hast dich doch sicherlich schon mal gewundert, wie die Post bei dir in den Briefkasten kommt.
Nee, nicht, weil die Postleute immer so einen großen Schlüsselring dabei haben, wo irgendwie 30.000 Schlüssel drin sind.
Also ich hab gerade noch ein Foto geschaut, ich hab's leider nicht gesehen. Eine Hausecke, die ich mal fotografiert habe, an der sieben solche Schlüsseltresoren erwandt waren. Das sah etwas durchlöchert aus und wild, weil es war bei jedem Schlüsseltresor ein anderes Produkt, Größe, Farbe, Bauform.
Okay, das heißt man sollte sich mal erkundigen, was im Schlüsseltresor drin liegt und welches Fabrikat das Schloss ist, was den Schlüsseltresor verschließt.
Wenn man ruhig schlafen möchte, lieber nicht.
Okay, dann lass ich das lieber und nehme stattdessen den Ray. Hallo, guten Abend. Du bist auch vom Chaos Computer Club allerdings aus München.
Genau, ich bin hier vom Tätig in München und ich wollte mal anrufen, ein bisschen was über unsere Schließanlage erzählen, weil wir einen elektronischen Selbstbau bei uns verwenden. Ja, ich werde erst mal kurz zur Motivation. Ich meine, ihr habt ja schon ein bisschen über elektronische Schließsysteme geredet.
Sind alle Scheiße.
Die größte natürlich mechanisch ist erstmal Scheiß, haben viele Schwächen. Und der große Kritikpunkt, den wir natürlich hatten als CCC, ist, dass die alle keine Open Source Krypto verwenden. Wir haben auch auf Schlossmessen, dass wir in München die Security, das ist ab und zu, wo viele Hersteller sich die Hand geben, haben mal Hersteller angesprochen, wollten nicht mal einen offenen Krypto verwenden. Ich meine, alle Online-Banken-Systeme verwenden offenen Krypto, das kann so schlecht nicht sein. Aber die haben offenbar alle riesige Angst davor, dass wenn der Krypto bekannt ist, das irgendwie ihrem Ansehen schadet.
Na vor allen Dingen ist es weniger ein Schutz gegen Einbrecher bei diesem System, sondern in der Regel ist es ein Schutz vor den eigenen Kunden, dass man Kundenbindung hat, dass man nämlich Nachschlüssel oder zusätzliche Karten nur vom gleichen Hersteller beziehen kann.
Genau, da könnte sich jemand am Ende eigene Tokens machen, den ich die tollste Programmiersoftware verwende oder irgendwie sowas. Aber die verkaufen das natürlich als Sicherheitsfeature. Meine Lieblingsaussage wäre, sie wäre ganz stolz darauf, dass selbst das BSI nicht den ganzen Code gesehen hat. Also das ist wirklich so. Mit NDA geben wir ein bisschen raus, aber niemanden haben wir bisher alles gegeben. Und das ist einfach sowas von lächerlich, dass wir gesagt haben, es gibt kein einziges kommerzielles Produkt, das man verwenden kann. Das Problem ist, es gibt halt auch kein einziges mechanisches Produkt, das man verwenden kann, weil gerade, wenn man so einen Clubraum oder sowas hat, da kommen Schlüssel gehen verloren und mechanische Schlüssel kann man nicht ungültig machen.
Und wie habt ihr es dann letztendlich gelöst?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir brauchen Elektronik und wir müssen sie selber programmieren. Und wir haben dann im Prinzip, gut, wir haben noch ein Schloss in der Tür, aber wir haben gesagt, Elektronik kann auch versagen. Aber dieses Schloss ist ein relativ sicheres und der Schlüssel hängt halt irgendwo hinterlegt, in Bankschließfächern versiegelt und so weiter und wird hoffentlich nie gebraucht. Und an der Innenseite des Schlosses haben wir so einen Motor montiert, den gibt es sogar als Fertigprodukt relativ billig für den für den Heimbereich. Der ist original so gedacht, dass man den mit so einem Funkschlüssel bedient und dann tut er den Motor aufmachen. Also quasi arme Leute, Funkschließung. Die haben wir natürlich erst mal komplett abgeklemmt, weil das ist wahrscheinlich auch mindestens genauso sicher. Ich nehme an, das macht 433 MHz unverschlüsselt oder so was. Da will ich jetzt nicht gesagt haben, aber auf jeden Fall kann man die Menschen nicht trauen. Und haben stattdessen dann den Mikrocontroller dran gehängt, den wir mit einer Foneira ansteuern.
Mit einer was?
Mit einer Foneira, das ist so ein WLAN Router, den man schön mit Linux versehen kann. Und jetzt haben wir es halt so gemacht, dass jeder einen SSH-Schlüssel hat, den er auf sein Handy spielen kann, da hat er seinen Putty drauf oder so was. Und wenn man sich mit einem bestimmten Login und seinem SSH-Schlüssel identifiziert, dann wird halt über den Mikrocontroller dieser Motor angesteuert und die Tür geht auf.
Oh mein Gott, das ist aber nicht total kompliziert. Also Stichwort User-Aczeptanz, das heute schon mal bei Netzhaut-Fotografie gefallen ist.
Ja, also sagen wir, das ist immer ein Essen, ist natürlich mit dem Handy die Tür aufsperren unter, beim Chaos Club. Also das ist ja wohl die Geek-Aczeptanz schlechthin.
Okay, zugeben.
Was gibt es Cooleres? Ist natürlich ein bisschen umständlich, wobei man zusagen muss, man sperrt das natürlich nicht alle fünf Minuten auf und zu. In der Regel der Erste, der in den Club halt kommt, muss aufsperren.
Man kann die Tür von innen auch noch von Hand öffnen.
Man kann die, wenn sie einmal aufgesperrt ist ja sowieso. Wir sperren uns in der Regel nicht ein, wenn wir drinnen sitzen.
Alles klar.
Also man kann das natürlich innen aber auch an so einem Rad drehen. Und zum Zusperren haben wir es auch so gemacht, dass man gar keinen Schlüssel braucht, sondern kann man innen den Knopf drücken, dann ist auf Zusperren geschaltet und wenn man die Tür dann zufallen lässt, wird über den Riedkontakt erkannt und der Motor sperrt ab.
So, dann hier kleine sportliche Herausforderungen an die Damen und Herren aus Berlin. Wie sieht es denn aus? Wie angreifbar ist das System? Ich meine, ihr habt heute über jedes Schloss schon einen Angriff gefunden.
Na im Zweifelsfall Tür eintreten.
Ja, okay, abgesehen davon. Wir reden noch über zerstörungsfrei.
Man würde dann in dem Fall natürlich den Infoneer angreifen. Man weiß ja nicht, wie akkordlich Software ist, die da draufläuft und SSH hat ja in der Vergangenheit.
Eines der vielen Telefone, die dazu verwendet werden, das aufzumachen.
Genau, die Telefone, das haben wir ja auch jetzt häufiger gesehen.
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, wobei natürlich der Vorteil davon darauf ist, dass man einen SSH-Schlüssel in der Regel, und das ist bei uns eigentlich mal kürt, wir können es nicht überprüfen, man kann es natürlich abschalten, aber die Leute sollen natürlich ihren SSH-Key mit einem Passwort versehen. Das heißt, da ist eine Passphrase drauf und selbst wenn das Telefon in fremde Hände gerät, kann damit niemand was anfangen, was natürlich nochmal ein deutlicher Vorteil gegenüber einem normalen Schlüssel ist, wenn der in seltsche Hände kommt, ist der in Sekunden kopiert.
Man muss schon einen Mobile Banking Trojaner umbauen, dass er die SSH Passphrase auch hinschreibt.
Das ist immerhin schon mal eine Herausforderung, die alles, was an normalen Schließsystemen vorhanden ist, mal übersteigt. Der Punkt ist, es hat auch einen mechanischen Schlüssel. Wir haben ja in München auch aktive SSDEV Gruppe, die auf der letzten H auch über mechanische Schließsysteme und deren Nachmachen referiert hat. Und es gibt quasi überhaupt kein mechanisches Schließsystem mehr, wo man nicht in der Lage ist, einen Schlüssel zu kopieren, unerlaubt. Ja, das heißt, wenn man einen Schlüssel in die Hand bekommt, normalerweise ist er eine Sicherungskarte, der Schlüsseldienst kann den nicht nachmachen und so weiter. Aber alle verfügbaren mechanischen Schlüssel, also ich weiß nicht, Ausnahmen möchte es geben, aber eigentlich alles, was wir kennen, kriegt man ohne Hilfe des Herstellers kopiert. Also wenn ein Schlüssel auch nur kurze Zeit in fremder Hand ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass eine Kopie existiert.
Also das übliche Verfahren ist, dass man so einen Abdruck macht in einer Masse, die nicht unähnlich der ist, die man immer ins Gesicht geschmiert bekommt, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine Zahnspange oder eine Krone oder sowas beim Zahnarzt bekommt.
Die Abgussmethode, es gibt auch Sachen, die haben Magnete drin. Die galt jetzt vor kurzem als unkopierbar. Damals ein bisschen mit beschäftigt, haben sie das auch hinbekommen. Das war was wir auf der H vorgestellt haben.
Also es gibt Schlüssel, da sind Magneten drin, die machen was?
Da sind Magneten drin, genau. Und deren Orientierung, und das ist nicht nur aus Süd, sondern es sind so gedrehte Magneten, gibt den Schließchord an. Da gibt es theoretisch dann auch 16 Millionen Schließungen. Und man kann sie halt optisch nicht auslesen, aber man kann eine Magnetlesekarte drauflegen und so weiter. Also die Quintessenz ist einfach, keines dieser mechanischen Systeme ist nicht kopierbar.
Was hast du für ein Schloss an der Wohnungstür?
In der Wohnung hab ich ja nichts Gewichtiges. Da hab ich ein ganz normales, normales Standeileinschloss.
Da hast du dein Handy, mit dem der Club aufgeht.
Na gut, damit beschäftigen wir uns das nächste Mal.
Aber zu dem Punktureintreten habt ihr natürlich recht, das Mechanische ist natürlich immer, was man, sag ich mal, Niederrangigter betrachtet. Uns ging es erst mal darum, dass wir sagen wollen, wir wollen erkennen, wenn jemand im Club war. Also, dass man Fenster eintreten kann. Wir sind jetzt nicht im 10. Stock oder so was. Da kann man Fenster einschlagen, man kann die Tür sicherlich eintreten mit genug Gewalt. Das geht ja quasi immer. Ein so gesichertes Gebäude gibt es ja quasi kaum.
Das müsste erst noch gebaut werden.
Muss man... Muss man ja auch bevor der Rechner aufgeht, oder?
Das stimmt. Na denn, viel Spaß und bis dann.
Danke schön.
So, und dann haben wir noch den Sven. Der hat noch eine Frage. Tja, da hat wohl irgendwas nicht funktioniert. Möglicherweise ist das irgendwie auch die Telefonlage. Hallo Sven.
Bin ich noch in der Leitung?
Ah, da ist er.
Du hast noch eine Frage.
Ein Kollege von mir wohnt in einem modernen Haus. Es sieht so aus, dass die Mieter alle einen Schlüssel für die Wohnungstür haben und auch einen für die Hoftür. Das ist also der gleiche Schlüssel. Manchens mit einem Schlüssel schließt man beide Türen. Und nun war die Situation die Folgende, dass neulich das Hoftürschloss fein säuberlich, störungsfrei ausgebaut und geklaut wurde. Jetzt fragen sich die Mieter so ein bisschen, kann man, wenn man das Ding hat, im stillen Kämmerlein ganz in Ruhe Nachschlüsse für die Wohnungstür entfalten?
Ja, natürlich. Also wenn man an das Profil rankommt, wie immer.
Theoretisch, man kann daraus mögliche Schlüssel rausfinden, aber explizit keinen konkreten für diese Wohnung.
Achso. Du könntest jetzt nicht sagen, ich möchte jetzt für die Wohnung um vierten Schloss den Schlüssel nachbauen, aber du könntest rausfinden, welche Arten von Schlüssel benutzt werden und damit könntest du sozusagen Rohling fürs Bumping bauen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Aber das wirft eine ganz andere, interessante Frage auf. Es gibt ja noch eine andere Öffnungstechnik aus dem Lockpickenbereich. Die sogenannte Impressionstechnik ist im breiten Volk nicht so ganz bekannt.
Da gab es mal diesen Russen, der in Brandenburg aus dem Knast getürmt ist mit der Methode.
Okay, Impressionstechnik.
Wie funktioniert das?
Er hat sich aus einem Stückchen Klochschüssel einen Schlüsselrohling gefeilt. Also es funktioniert so, wenn du einen Schlüssel reinsteckst, der jetzt nicht passt, und du versuchst ihn hin und her zu bewegen, dann fangen diese Stifte an, auf der Oberfläche des Schlüssels zu kratzen. Und dann siehst du, dass es da gekratzt hat, dann feilst du ein Stückchen runter, dann machst du das noch mal, und irgendwann erwischst du den richtigen Abstand, sodass es sich drehen kann an der Stelle. Dann hinterlässt der Stift keine Kratzer mehr. Das heißt irgendwie reinstecken, ein bisschen schütteln, gucken, feilen, reinstecken, ein bisschen schütteln, gucken, feilen, bis das Schloss offen ist.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ein Generalschlüssel immer am wenigsten tief eingeschnitten ist. Dass man nicht durch Abfeilen einen höheren Wert den Schlüssel bekommen kann.
Ah ja, aber das Schloss könnte dann nur dazu, also das ausgebaut Schloss in diesem Fall, könnte nur dazu dienen, sozusagen den Schlüssel für dieses Schloss jetzt nachzubauen?
Nein, das weiß man sogar in der Art nicht, ob für dieses oder für irgendein anderes Schloss.
Aber wie soll das mit dem anderen Schloss funktionieren?
Naja, dieser Zylinder, der aus der Hoftür ausgebaut wird, ist ja ein Zentralzylinder, also wo viele verschiedene Schlüssel einschließen. Also wo ein breiter Schließkanal ist und mit Sicherheit auch unterschiedliche Plättchen. Und dadurch weiß man jetzt nicht, welcher Schlüssel, der da schließen könnte, ist wofür.
Das sieht man dem Schloss nicht an. Das heißt, ich baue alle Schlüssel, die sich mit diesem Schloss bauen lassen, dann komme ich möglicherweise noch irgendwo anders.
Richtig, also 20 verschiedene Schlüssel bauen, die alle genau dieses Schloss öffnen, was sie für andere Schlösser öffnen, weißt du nicht.
Aber was kannst du denn ausprobieren?
Ich habe noch eine Technik, wie man auf Schlüssel kommt, und zwar die wirklich guten Leute für die...
Warte mal, ich würde ehrlich sagen, Sven, deine Frage ist jetzt beantwortet. Super, dann viel Spaß damit. So, jetzt.
Also Impressioning hatten wir ja schon, da steckt man ins Schloss rein und wackelt, um zu sehen, wie weit man runterfallen muss. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass diese Tiefen der Rillen, also der Vertiefungen in dem Schloss, die können nicht beliebig sein, sondern gibt es dann von 0 bis 9 und auch entsprechende Stiftlängen nur. Und es gibt Leute, die können also einem Schlüssel ansehen, wie tief der eingefällt wurde. Das heißt, wenn dein Schlüssel rumliegt, gucken die kurz drauf, dann sehen die irgendwie 68427. Dann können die einen Schlüsselholing in die Hand nehmen, dann fallen sie kurz 62487 rein und machen deine Tür auf.
Okay, das sind aber dann so Ausnahmetalente, so fotografisches, gedächtnismäßig oder wie?
Oder Leute mit ganz viel langer Weile.
Aber sind diese Abstände überall gleich sozusagen? Oder sind die dann wieder von Schlüsselart zu Schlüsselart unterschiedlich?
Pro Schlosstyp schon.
Also Hersteller zu Hersteller mindestens, aber teilweise auch in unterschiedlichen Produkten beim selben Hersteller abweichend.
Okay, das heißt also, wenn jemand wirklich viel Zeit hat, dann kann man das machen. Gibt es noch was?
Ich glaube, Öffnungsmethoden bin ich jetzt erstmal durch.
Das mit dem Schlüssel nachmachen, also an den Schlüssel kommen, ist natürlich ganz klassisch, genau über den Finger drücken, teleobjektiv, Schlüssel fotografieren, da gab es ja auch schon einige schöne Demonstrationen. Da braucht man auch kein fotografisches Gedächtnis für dann mehr.
Exotische Schlüssel und Schlosstypen hätte ich noch anzubieten als Tagesordnungspunkt. Zum Beispiel in Berlin, teilweise noch verbreitet, sind sogenannte Durchsteckschlüssel. Das ist selten geworden, gibt es aber immer noch.
Für Haustüren, ne?
Für Haustüren, ja. Du kennst das, ne?
Ja, wo man nicht, wenn die zugeschlossen wurde einmal, da kann man nicht mehr durch die Tür gehen, ohne da irgendwie auszuschließen. Du schließt auf auf der einen Seite, musst den Schlüssel dann durchstecken und dann schließt du wieder zu und dann kannst du ihn erst wieder rausnehmen.
Genau, man kriegt ihn nur raus, wenn das Schloss abgeschlossen ist. Man kann ihn aber auf die andere Seite der Tür schieben, dass man auf der einen Seite aufschließen kann, rumlaufen und auf der anderen Seite wieder rein.
Richtig, und dann haben diese Schlösser noch ein ganz anderes, raffiniertes, kleines Detail. Und zwar ist in dem Schloss, hinter dem sogenannten Stulb, wo die Falle und der Riegel rauskommen, ein kleiner Hebel. Und in dem Schließblech, also da wo das dann einschließt, ist ein Magnet. Und nur wenn die Tür zu ist, wird durch diese Magnet, dieser kleine Hebel angezogen. Und nur dann kann man schließen. Also bei diesen Durchsteckschlössern ist es so, dass wenn die Tür offen ist, kann man nicht schließen wie bei anderen Schlüsseln, weil dann dieser Hebel sperrt.
Gibt es auch besondere Angriffsmethoden, zum Beispiel für Leute, die genervt sind vor den Durchsteckschlössern? Weil das ja oft bei Häusern sind, wo der Hauswirt dann irgendwie 19 Uhr die Haustür abschliesst.
Ja, man hat da doch gerade angedeutet, man nimmt einen kleinen Magneten, weil dann kann man die Tür auch abschließen, während sie eigentlich gar nicht zu ist und kriegt den Schlüssel raus.
Oder flacher Pfeil.
Okay, so schnell habe ich jetzt nicht mehr geschaltet. Sorry. Jetzt haben wir noch ganz schnell zwei Leute. Tim? Ganz schnell.
Bei uns war es einmal so, da ist die Tür zugefallen. Dann haben wir, weil quasi bei uns es so ist, dass der Türrahmen von außen über die Tür rüber geht, bis zu einem gewissen Grad, das quasi angebohrt auf Höhe des Schnappers und dann einfach mit dem Schraubenzieher den Schnapper reingedrückt und aufgemacht.
Das ist richtig. Das wird auch von vielen verwendet. Wir benutzen es zum Beispiel gar nicht, weil es ja wieder eine Beschädigung des Strahlens darstellt.
Und außerdem braucht man dafür auch eine Bohrmaschine mit Strom.
Naja, Bohrmaschinen mit Akku sind relativ wenig. Aber das Problem ist selbst, wenn man zu spachtelt oder schmiert, meistens dann sehr sporadisch oder hässlich, dann sieht man das. Und der nächste braucht dann wirklich nur noch dadurch piken, durch die wahrscheinlich weiche Zuschmiermasse.
Aber ihr habt das sozusagen gemacht, weil ihr häufiger vor dem Problem standet. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Genau das meinte ich.
Irgendwie hat sich die Tür verzogen oder so.
Da haben wir noch mal zwei extra Löcher gemacht.
Sehr gut. Na dann viel Spaß mit dem Schraubenzieher, dem Loch in der Tür. Das war der Tim und dann haben wir zum Schluss noch Manu. Hallo.
Hallo.
Du hast auch noch eine Methode zum Schloss eröffnen.
Ja, und da müsst ihr immer die Dings aufmachen, da müsst ihr eine Cola-Flasche, müsst richtig Coca-Cola nehmen. Und immer von oben reinfahren und dann kriegt ihr das Schloss mit rum, weil die ist irgendwie so komisch gewölbt und durch das schräge Abschneiden kriegt man das dann wieder auf.
Hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ich auch nicht.
Wenn du von Coca-Cola oben so ein Stück abschneidest, musst du das einmal halbieren und da kannst du das in der Tür reinfahren und da hast du die Rundung drum und dann einmal runterziehen und durch die Schräge kriegst du das Schloss dann auf.
Sozusagen statt der Karte eine Coca-Cola-Flasche.
Richtig, das hatten wir schon angesprochen. Das geht in der Tat, weil das Material der Cola-Flasche dafür sehr gut geeignet ist.
Also es kommt drauf an, ich hab schon probiert, es war natürlich keine Coca-Cola-Flasche, sondern was ich nur gerade dabei hatte, es war aber auch gerundetes Plastik und es hat nicht funktioniert.
Daran hat es gelegen.
Zum allerletzten möchte ich zu einem letzten Typ Schlösser kommen, das sind diese Notebook-Schlösser, mit denen man sozusagen Notebook an der Bibliothek oder an der Uni anschließen kann. Da gab es vor ein paar Jahren diesen schönen Hack mit dem Klopapier. Einfach ein Stück festes Pappe reinnehmen und solange wackeln, wie es das Schloss von alleine aufspringt.
Oder Stifthülsen gehen dafür wohl auch ganz toll.
Ist das immer noch so?
Ja.
Würde ich davon ausgehen?
Also die haben sich das...
Das ist prinzipbedingt.
Aber das war noch zu sagen, damals gab es auch irgendwie tausende YouTube-Videos und ich dachte, da hätten die sich hier mal was Neues ausgedacht.
Ja, glaubst du, davon sie verkaufszahlen, dieser Schlösser zurückgegangen?
Nein, und ich dachte, das liegt daran, dass sie sich was Neues ausgedacht haben. Nein.
Ah, du hast zu viel gedacht.
Ja, das könnte möglicherweise der Fall gewesen sein. Gut, jetzt haben wir noch quasi zwei Minuten. Was empfiehlt man jetzt? Am Ende eines solchen Chaosradios stehen wir mal da und denken so, okay, es ist alles kaputt. Deswegen möchte ich sozusagen nochmal die Frage vom Anfang wiederholen. Wir müssen jetzt nicht irgendwie alle Angst erfüllt hinter unseren Wohnungstüren kauern und denken, oh Gott, da kommt gleich jemand rein.
Also ganz wichtig ist auf jeden Fall zweimal abschließen. Viele Leute gehen einfach runter und ziehen die Tür hinter sich zu, weil sie ja nun mal einkaufen gehen. Abschließen hilft doch deutlich gegen viele der leichten Öffnungsmethoden, die wir besprochen haben, dieses Ganze mit dem Karte reinstecken und dem Draht und der Cola-Flasche. Das sind ja alles zugezogene Türen. Das ist ein Druckschluss und viele sind einfach zu faul. Diese Faulheit muss man schon mal abstellen.
Und dann, du sagtest gerade zweimal zuschließen. Warum nicht nur einmal?
Dann muss man zweimal picken.
Na ja, da gibt es auch Techniken für. Aber prinzipiell erstmal ja. Und zweitens kommt der Riegel dann auch weiter raus. Und streng genommen, versicherungstechnisch ist auch nur eine Tür versichert, die abgeschlossen ist. Und abgeschlossen heißt, dass der Riegel 21 oder 20 Millimeter ausgeschlossen ist. Und das ist in der Regel erst nach der zweiten Tour.
Das ist ja mal ein interessanter Fakt, den man sich noch mal hinter die Ohren schreiben kann. Also unter einmal zuschließen zahlt die Versicherung meistens nicht, weil dann der Schließriegel...
Wenn sie so genau darauf achten. Also so ist es streng genommen im Versicherungsgesetz. Und noch ein Trugschluss, also der Einbrecher kommt selten nachts. Die häufigste Einbruchsstunde ist zwischen 12 und 13 Uhr, weil die Leute einfach arbeiten oder in der Schule sind.
Das ist tatsächlich auch so. Also alle Einbrüche, von denen ich gehört habe in Wohnungen, sind auch alle tatsächlich tagsüber passiert, im Sinne von ich war nur kurz weg oder ich war arbeiten. Es ist eigentlich auch so, es gibt diese schöne Bauanweisheit, wie der Blitz schlägt niemals zweimal ein, wenn einmal eingebrochen wurde.
Definitiv nicht.
Das gilt da nicht, sondern da würde man eher nochmal wiederkommen, weil es schon einfach war.
Ja, gerade im Gewerbe werden Leute, wenn sie einmal besucht wurden, häufiger besucht, weil dann wissen sie ja, was drinnen ist und dann wissen sie, was sie so für Taschen brauchen und...
Erstmal gucken und dann nochmal wiederkommen. Na gut, wir hoffen, dass euch das nicht passiert. Das war das Chaosradio 164 mit Andreas, Henrik und Simon. Vielen Dank euch drei fürs Vorbeikommen. Und ihr könnt diese ganze Sendung natürlich nochmal hören als Podcast. Auf chaosradio.de geht ihr bestimmt irgendwie in den nächsten zwei Minuten online. Irgendjemand hat ja immer mitgeschnitten. Und sonst auch auf fritz.de, da gibt's nochmal den hochoffiziellen Podcast. Ich wünsche viel Spaß und gleich Nightfight mit Henrik Schröder. Der wird euch Punkrock um die Ohren hauen. Mir bleibt nur noch ein Spruch. Macht immer schön eure Backups. Schließt die Wohnungstür ab und lasst sie nicht überwachen.